Kurz vor 3 Minuten
LUL
Ob ich es mal schaffe einen Stream zu machen, ohne dass ich einen deutschen Satz sage?
Das muss doch drin sein.
Alter, was geht mit der Musik ab?
Stimmt, warum habe ich eigentlich keinen Dark Mode?
Warum macht das dieses komische Ding nicht?
Ah, deswegen, damn.
Ist es absicht, dass es keine Discord Ankündigung gibt?
Das muss am Bord liegen, wenn es keine Discord Ankündigung gibt.
Ja, die sollten mal wirklich, Twitch-Zuschauer, die sollten mal wirklich einen LCD mit schwarzer
Hintergrundbeleuchtung erfinden.
Also Leute, ich erkläre euch mal kurz, was wir heute machen, und zwar, ihr kennt ja noch
mein Softwareraum-Video und ich habe ja gestern den Stream gemacht, wo ich gesagt habe, dass
mir mein Heim-Automatisierung-Server verreckt ist.
Also das Ding hier, ich kann es ja nochmal zeigen, hier, RIP, also das ist schon glücklicherweise
alles ab, zum Glück ist da nicht auf irgendwelche Sticks drauf gefallen oder so.
So, und gestern haben wir ein bisschen geguckt, wie wir die Kiste zum Laufen bekommen, und
da ist mir aufgefallen, eigentlich war die Idee von mir ziemlich bescheuert, ich wollte
nämlich wieder viel zu viel auf eine Kiste machen.
Aktuell ist es ja so, wie man in diesem Softwareraum-Video gesehen hat von 2017, es lief eine ganze
Weile bei mir ja alles auf dieser fetten 4HE-Kiste, Internet, Fernseh, Nextcloud, sind auch alles,
ich vergesse immer, was ich laufen habe, Nass, Git, Zeug, alles, ja, Musik ist ziemlich
laut, ich weiß auch nicht, was geht mit der Musik eigentlich ab, the fuck, ne die ist nicht
laut, die Musik, die Musik ist nervig, Wouts, Abonnierstufe 1, Poggers, äh, ich mach mal
die Musik, klar ist das, so, ja, ich glaube so ist ganz gut, so, ähm, ja, so, ja, ich
bin jetzt zu leise, oder, wobei, nee, nee, wow, Alter, warum ist mein Mikro so laut,
hallo, Test, nee, ich glaube, nee, eigentlich ist es okay, also, ähm, wie gesagt, mal meinen
Satz fertig zu machen, also, eine ganze Mist bei mir lief ja auf dieser 4HE-Kiste, ähm,
und, ähm, ich, ich bin jetzt, ich hab jetzt ja Internetzugang auch, ich hab jetzt ja schon
angefangen, das ein bisschen auseinander zu ziehen, ich hab jetzt noch einen MikroTik-Router
fürs Internet, ich hab jetzt diese eine 4HE-Kiste für Heimautomatisierung, war ja auch alles
da drauf, ähm, auch, äh, UniFi für den Access Point war da drauf, äh, UniFi kommt auf
einen eigenen Raspberry Pi drauf, Internet geht jetzt über, ähm, einen MikroTik-Router,
deckt und VoIP gedönnt, macht einen Fritzbox, die da rumgammelt, ähm, Heimautomatisierung
macht diese Kiste, wenn sie nicht kaputtgegangen wäre, und demnächst diese Kiste, 10G nass
macht auch diese Kiste mit, und ich, ich wollte jetzt eigentlich den Fehler machen, wieder
den TV-Server, wohlgemerkt, ich guck keinen TV, das ist für meine Mutter, die guckt immer
TV, die weiß nicht, das ist halt, äh, pre-Boomer ist das noch, das ist noch nicht mal, wobei,
doch, das ist eigentlich fast schon Boomer, ähm, zumindest, die will Fernseh gucken,
und deswegen hab ich halt noch ein TV-Server laufen, mit TV-Headend, und, die Sache ist
die, ja, ich kanns auch nicht verstehen, ich kanns wirklich auch nicht verstehen, aber,
wenn das nicht funktioniert, wär ich permanent genervt mit irgendwas, und deswegen, guck mal,
wie hier, der Patrick kommentiert hat vor, vor zwei Jahren, so, und deswegen, ähm, machen
wir es nicht so wie geplant, nämlich, nicht noch hier den TV-Empfang, auch hiermit drauf,
sondern, ich bin heut morgen auf ne richtig, äh, Big Brain Idee gekommen, äh, diesmal
gibt's The Last of Us kostenlos, ich hab The Last of Us schon in alt und in neu, braucht
es nicht noch ein drittes Mal, auch wenn es ein gutes Game ist, so, und ich bin, äh,
ich hab Big Brain Idee, und zwar hab ich drauf gekommen, dass ich noch so ne Kiste da hab,
das ist ein Ultroid HC2, das ist im Prinzip, dieses Ding da, mit so nem Rahmen, wo man
ne Festplatte dran machen kann, ja, es gibt auch ein Gehäuse, aber das offizielle Gehäuse
sieht kacke aus, da muss man sich irgendwas 3D drucken, oder so, das ist halt mega billig,
kost 50 Euro, oder so, und du hast, äh, oder weniger, hast halt alles dabei, was du brauchst,
deswegen hab ich mir gedacht, ich nehm dieses Teil, guck mal, ob's da ein schöneres Bild
dafür von gibt, ähm, ich nehm dieses Teil, hier da, das ist es, es ist nicht viel, nicht
viel Rechner, ne, ich guck mal, was das Ding neu kostet, vielen bolliger, ja, warum ist
das so teuer, ja, guckt euch mal an, wie hässlich das offizielle Gehäuse ist, da 3D druck ich
mir irgendwas, hat übrigens 8 CPU Kern, das Ding ist ziemlich, ziemlich geschwind, so,
da nehm ich dieses Ding hier, und ich hab mir gekauft ein WinTV Dual HD, ein USB Dual-Tuner-Stick
für DVBC, das Ding hier, und da hab ich mir gedacht, ich nehm einfach dieses Ding, für
welchen 3D-Drucker hast du ein Anycubic, frag mich nicht, Anycubic i3 Mega, oder so, so,
und ich nehm dieses Ding, das hab ich schon seit einem Jahr hier rumliegen, und hab's
für nichts verwendet, mach da den, äh, TV-Stick dran, stell das Ding neben den Fernseher,
als, als quasi TV-Server, oder irgendwo, irgendwo, irgendwo anders hin, und lass das
da für alle Zeit TV-Servern und Scheiß drauf, also wirst du damit dann keine Full HD, nein,
kann ich nicht, äh, was, also, für nicht GEZ, nein, kann ich nicht, wobei doch kann
ich, weil Big Brain, ähm, also ich, nein, über Kabel kann man nicht, das stimmt, aber,
was man machen kann ist, ähm, und da hab ich vor, mal nen Test-Modal auszuprobieren, ob
das ne Alternative ist, man kann mit Setu, oder wie man das ausspricht, die haben zwar
bloß 720p, aber, die haben die privaten Sender auch in HD, und es gibt nen TV-Headend-Skript,
was das verbindet mit dem TV-Server, das muss man mal ausprobieren, aber ganz ehrlich,
nachdem ich kein Fernseher gucke, ist mir der Scheiß egal, solange ich da keine Beschwerden
bekomme, dass irgendwie Fernseher unerträglich Scheiße aussieht, und es mir permanent jemand
auf den Sack geht, ist okay, ja, ich kann damit, also ich kann damit eh leben, dass die
privaten Sender nicht in HD sind, ich gucke ja eh kein Fernseher, ja, also insofern ist
mir das egal, und die guckt eh zum größten Teil öffentlich-rechtliches, die guckt irgendwie
so Zeugs wie, was weiß ich, was gibt's denn da immer, was gibt's denn da immer, von irgendwie
hessenschönste Wanderwege, oder irgendwie rosamunde Pilcher, oder irgendwie so ein Tatort,
ey alter Tatort, genau, so ein Crap wird da geguckt, ne, totaler Müll, aber ich werd
genervt, wenn's nicht funktioniert, deswegen wird das Ding jetzt genommen, TV-Stick dran,
und gut ist, als Frontend ist es ja nach wie vor ein Shield-TV mit Kodi drauf, das wird
auch so bleiben, ich hab mir schon überlegt, ob ich nicht einfach den Tuner versuchen soll,
den Tuner ans Shield-TV direkt zu machen, also das Shield-TV hat ja auch, das Shield-TV
hat ja auch eins, ich glaub zwei USB-Anschlüsse, ich hab mal auch schon überlegt, ob ich den
Tuner nicht direkt ans Shield-TV mache, dann müsste ich da irgendwie TV Headend drauf
kriegen aufs Shield-TV, und irgendwie noch ne externe Festplatte, wo das dann draufschreibt
und so, ich weiß nicht, ob das so zuverlässig ist, wenn das Shield-TV einfach alles macht,
weiß ich nicht, deswegen werd ich jetzt mal zumindest das runterzukriegen, also ich weiß
ich, das müsste ich mal ausprobieren, aber es gab irgendwelche Probleme, warum es mit
dem Shield-TV nicht, ich hatte mir das im Vorfeld überlegt, ich komm aber nicht mehr
drauf, warum ich mit dem Shield-TV nicht machen wollte, was war das denn, ach ja ich weiß,
genau, weil ich die aktuell bestehende TV Headend Installation umziehen muss, und da
muss ich ein paar Custom-Anpassungen machen, ich weiß nicht, wie gut das auf dem Shield-TV
funktioniert, so, zumindest deswegen kommt die Kiste daneben als TV-Server und gut ist,
da passt, ihr seht's ja hier, da passt vorne genau ne Festplatte rein, alter das offizielle
Case ist wirklich schon hardcore hässlich, oder, da kommt dann ne Festplatte rein, und
es ist irgendwie ne 2TB Platte, ich zieh da drauf alles um an Aufnahmen, installier TV
Headend, mach nen Sender-Suchlauf, mach Sender-Logos rein und fertig, das wars, fertig, dann wird
es dahingestellt und da vor sich hin TV-Servern ohne dass ich mich jemals wieder drum kümmern
muss, ab und zu kriegt es vielleicht mal ein Update, wenn es irgendwie Senderlisten oder
so Updates gibt, Alter, der Nightbot wills ja mal wissen, XD, Foggers, ja und das machen
wir heute, das heißt, als erstes muss ich meine VM starten, ohne VM geht nix, das ist
ja bekannt, ne, also Großeltern-TV, Nix-Action, ja, so könnte man das ausdrücken, zumal ne,
ich hab ja auch schon gesagt, wenn sie will, kann sie meinen Amazon-Account verwenden,
mit Amazon Prime, weil da hast du HD, also 4K, da kann man den Fernseher wenigstens mal
was sinnvolles verwenden, äh, der Server ist aus, ups, ähm, da kann man den Fernseher
wenigstens mal was sinnvolles verwenden, aber, ups, wie sieht meine Schrift komisch aus,
Moment wohl, doch, ne, das ist richtige Schrift, passt, alles gut, naja, ähm, also wird auf
dem TV-Buddy eigentlich nur YouTube und, nein, ich benutze den Fernseher kaum, das einzige,
wo ich den Fernseher verwende ist, ähm, ab und zu mal für die Switch, ein Filmchen, ja,
ich verwende den Fernseher kaum, ich hab ja hier drüben noch einen, also kleineren stehen,
plus die zwei Monitore, ich brauch nix, das ist ein Wohnzimmer, da bin ich kaum, die sollen
da ihr, die sollen da ihr, ähm, ihr, keine Ahnung, Opa-Oma-Programm gucken, das ist okay,
Hauptsache es funktioniert, das geht mir damit keiner auf den Kicks, ähm, deswegen installieren
wir das Ganze jetzt, ich hab den Stick, wo hab ich das Ding jetzt hingestellt, äh, wo
hab ich jetzt, hm, ach da, ähm, genau, deswegen, der Plan ist, hallo, ah, ich bin auf dem falschen
Desktop mit meiner Maus, ähm, der Plan ist, installieren hier drauf jetzt, ähm, wir machen
uns eine Micro SD-Karte, machen da ein aktuelles Ubuntu 1804 drauf, für ARM, was halt da drauf
läuft, muss ich mal gucken, was das, ähm, so sagt, was da supported ist, und, ähm,
dann machen wir hier den einzigen USB-Anschluss, machen wir diesen Tuner-Stick rein, machen
eine Festplatte drauf, machen eine Festplatte rein, installieren TV-Hatend, und, ähm, machen
Sendersuchlauf, so, im Endeffekt ist der Plan jetzt, Alzheimer schon zugeschlagen, aha,
so, deswegen, während ich Chat lese, downloade ich mal, das aktuelle, was auch immer, aktuelle
Ubuntu oder sowas von denen, von denen gibt, mal so eine Frage, für einen angehenden Attila,
was ist denn ein realistisches Einstiegsgehalt für ein Feezy in FFM, sorry, für die Off-Topic-Frage,
ähm, also 35k auf jeden Fall, 35-40k, so, ungefähr, 35-40k, 35-40k, 35-40k, 35-40k,
so, ungefähr, vielleicht je nach Laden mehr, wie heißt das, BigBrain-E-Mode, richtig, 5-Hat,
also 40, also Richtung 40k sollte es heutzutage einst schon eher gehen, wenn ich mir damals
mal recht über, überlegt, ja, überlege, ja, also 35-40k, also Frankfurt, ja, woanders
vielleicht weniger, aber das sollte ich nicht davon abhalten, erstmal ein bisschen mehr
zu sagen, ne, sag dir ruhig erstmal ein bisschen mehr, nicht, dass die im Endeffekt easy mehr
bezahlen und du quasi schon unter denen anfängst, ne, ok, Download, Linux, Ubuntu, was hat man
da, 1804, 3, Colonel 4114, äh, 414, immer in Erfahrung mit dem Pi 4 gehen Boot-Vorgänge
deutlich schneller, ist mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen, ja, wir downloaden das mal, Main-Server, AC2
und dann downloaden wir mal das da, das sieht doch, Minimal, ne, Minimal wollen wir nicht
made, Minimal, Minimal, das ist das aktuelle, ja, gut, dann downloaden wir mal, schön,
äh, gleich mal eine Frage, die mich schon länger juckt, hat mir jetzt die erste Fachliteratur
geholt zu Go, weil die Profs ja immer so davon schwärmen, will ja auch so BigBrain wie du
werden, also wenn Go gleich BigBrain ist, dann bin ich nicht BigBrain, weil ich bin in Go
nicht so der geile Owner, ja, ähm, wollte fragen, wieviel Fachliteratur du gelesen hast
und was deine Meinung zu langen Literaturlisten in der Informatik ist, ja gut, zu Informatikstudium
kann ich jetzt wenig sagen, ähm, was da gerade angesagt ist, aber zu dem, was ich gelesen
hab, kann ich was sagen, es hält sich in Grenzen, also ich hab mal, ich hab ganz am Anfang,
als ich angefangen hab zu programmieren, damals dieses C Sharp Open Book, paar mal gelesen,
ja, paar mal, ähm, nicht alles, so die wichtigsten Sachen, ein paar mal, und ab und zu ein paar
Sachen, ich hab ein Bash Buch gelesen, ich hab ein WPF Buch mal gelesen, aber so insgesamt
komm ich vielleicht auf 10, auf 10 Bücher oder so, der Rest ist, ist Internet gucken,
offizielle Bücher lesen, offizielle Dokus lesen, irgendwelche kostenlosen Webcasts oder so,
was immer gut ist, wenn man was lernen will, zu schauen, ob es irgendwelche Vorträge gibt,
weil die Sache ist einfach die, wenn du, wenn du, wenn du so Sachen wie Go anguckst, ne,
Go ist, ist so beliebt, das Internet ist voll mit Tutorials, du weißt erst mal gar nicht
genau, was du dir angucken sollst, also ist richtig gut, wenn du vielleicht irgendwelche
Konferenztalks hast, die sich mit aktuellen Themen beschäftigen, wenn du die Basics kannst,
oder halt gucken, was irgendwie halbwegs offiziell aussieht, oder was empfohlen wird, oder so.
Achso, Go, weil du Bock drauf hast, ja gut, also Go ist definitiv nicht schlecht zum Einstieg.
Ja, ich auch, meine Abo-Hinweise, ja, die sind, meine Abo-Hinweise sind mittlerweile
richtig next-level.
Äh, Programmiersprache bei Google, ich bin mir selbst ehrlich gesagt gar nicht mal so
sicher, wie viel Sachen bei Google wirklich in Go programmiert werden, weil Mozilla,
weiß ich, Mozilla macht wenigstens Teile von Firefox in Rust, äh, ich hab eher den
Eindruck, dass Go eben ne schöne, ne schöne Einstiegssprache ist von Google, und dass
Google selbst zwar auch Sachen in Go macht, aber jetzt nicht unbedingt, äh, primär.
Hast du mal WoW gezockt, ja, vor 10 Jahren, oder so, als das rausgekommen ist?
So, also, wo hab ich noch den Micro SD-Karten-Reader?
Hier, zack, wenn wir ein bisschen Progress machen heute, sonst, sonst dauert's wieder
so lang.
Downloads, da ist es, Part, sind wir noch nicht fertig mit dem Download?
Monkeys, was ist denn das für ein Download-Speed, jetzt, hä, hab ich das eben gar nicht downloaded
oder so, oder hab ich einfach richtig rein PP-Gard, ich hab richtig rein PP-Gard, oder,
ich hab das eben nicht angeklickt, kann das sein?
Oder doch?
Leute, Unity Media, Alter, ihr werdet es nicht glauben, ey.
Also, ich muss, ich muss mich einmal über Unity Media aufregen, und einmal muss ich
Unity Media loben.
So, und zwar, ich hab euch ja erzählt, oder ich hab's ja auf Twitter geschrieben, ich
hab ja upgraded von 100 Down, 5 oder 6 Up, auf 400 Down, 5, äh, 40 Up, hab ich jetzt.
Ich habe bei so ziemlich jedem Schritt, wo ich diese Tarifumstellung gemacht hab, hab
ich immer dabei gesagt, also ich hab davor 10 Mal gefragt, kann ich mein IPv4, ähm,
kann ich mein IPv4 behalten?
Und jeder, jeder, immer haben sie mir versichert, ja, das ist überhaupt kein Problem, ähm,
in der Bestellung hab ich nach jeder, ähm, Nachricht gesagt, ja, IPv4 erhalten, alle
immer gesagt, ja, alles klar, und überhaupt kein Problem, und heute guck ich auf meine
Connectbox, und sehe, ich hab DS Lite.
So, dann erste Mal auf Twitter gegangen, und den Support, äh, geflamed, oder, oder den,
den Unity Media, den Unity Media Typ angeschrieben, und die, die erste Antwort von denen, das,
die fand, die fand ich schon irgendwie, äh, echt aus, aus der Reihe, echt schon daneben,
die erste Antwort, die ich, also ich hab, ich hab, ich hab ihnen geschrieben, ähm, irgendwie,
es wurd's ja, an jeder, an jeder Stelle wurde quasi versichert, ähm, IPv6, äh, IPv4 bleibt
halt, und, äh, jetzt ist es halt DualStack, sollen sie wieder umstellen, so.
Die erste Antwort, die ich hier erhalten hab, von unseren Kollegen, von Unity Media hier,
von denen da, war, ja, IPv4 können wir nur buchen, wenn du zusätzlich Power Upload
dazu buchst, nochmal drei Euro im Monat, soll ich das jetzt buchen?
Nein, das sollst du nicht buchen, du sollst, du sollst das machen, was ihr mir in jedem
Schritt in der Auftragsabwicklung zugesichert habt.
Außerdem gibt es für meinen Tarif gar kein Power Upload, weil bei mir Power Upload schon
mit dabei ist.
Ich hab irgend so einen komischen Langzeit-Bestands-Kundentreue-Tarif, für den sie mich umgestellt haben, und da gibt
es kein extra Power Upload, Power Upload ist dabei, ich hab 440 ab.
Also, da wissen sie, die wissen schon mal gar nicht, wovon sie da irgendwie anscheinend
reden.
So, da war ich schon wieder auf 180 heute Morgen, hab ich gesagt, wollt ihr mich verarschen,
ey.
Und dann hat halt der oder die vom Support gesagt, sie müssen jetzt auf DualStack, also
sie haben irgendwie die Anweisung, sie müssen jetzt auf DualStack umschalten, ich hab das
sogar gescreenshotted.
Poke-Chucks, also Twitter-PNs, sogar Screenshot ist sogar noch im Chatverlauf drinne und alles.
Also, ich gehe auch mal davon aus, dass es rechtlich nicht so ohne weiteres haltbar wäre,
wenn es quasi in der, quasi beim Auftrag mit zugesagt wurde, aber ganz ehrlich, ich hab
kein Bock da irgendwie als Unity-Media, zumindest, also ich glaube, ich hab bessere Druckmittel
als beim Anwalt, ich werde die einfach anflamen vor 180.000 Leuten auf YouTube, wenn's nicht
funktioniert.
So, und danach hat die geschrieben, sie müssen das alles auf, oder der hat geschrieben, sie
müssen das alles auf DualStack umstellen, weil sie haben irgendwie die Anweisung, alles
auf DualStack umzustellen.
Ich hab gesagt, ja gut, aber ihr habt das gesagt, aber, aber, wenn du echt, also das
hab ich so mehr oder weniger 1 zu 1 geschrieben, aber wenn du echt in DualStack meinst, also
vollwertiges IPv4 und vollwertiges IPv6, dann hätte ich nix dagegen, aber der Slide
geht auf keinen Fall.
So, und dann hat er geantwortet, so nach dem Motto, irgendwie 40 Minuten später, wahrscheinlich
musste er erst mal sich umhören, ja, und dann hat er geschrieben, ok, du kriegst das
richtigen DualStack, wird im Lauf des Tages umgestellt.
Ich hab ihn dann nochmal gefragt, ja, ok, hab ich dann auch wieder die üblichen IPv4
Optionen, wie Port weiterleiten und sowas, in der Connectbox, dann hat er gesagt, ja,
das taucht im Laufe des Tages alles wieder auf.
Lauf des Tages ist auf 4 Stunden, gucken wir mal, ich hab noch nicht in die Connectbox
reingeguckt, ich warte auch bis morgen, bis ich in die Connectbox reingucke.
Und wenn das morgen noch nicht der Fall ist, flame ich so weiter.
Und diesmal nicht direkt at Unity Media, sondern ich muss das stufenweise erhöhen.
Als erstes wird öffentlich auf Twitter ein paar Mal geschrieben, dann wird wieder mal
öffentlich auf Twitter geschrieben, während ich gerade im Livestream bin, dass die Leute
das ganz natürlich schön sehen und schön liken und schön Unity Media flamen, und wenn
gar nix hilft, mach ich halt ein Video.
Und dann hat sich, da hat sich das letzte Mal auch was gerührt, das ging ganz schnell
das letzte Mal, weil ich glaube nämlich immer noch nicht, dass meine erste Umstellung von
Duels der Kleid auf IPv4 einfach ging, weil ich so nett gefragt habe, sondern einfach
weil ich zu sehr genervt habe.
Naja, zumindest angeblich wird das alles wieder umgestellt, sollte das der Fall sein, dann
werd ich's mal umgedreht machen, dann mach ich ein Video, wo ich mal den Unity Media
Twitter Support lobe.
Das mach ich dann, dann mach ich das übelste, dann mach ich das übertriebenste Schleimvideo
für den Unity Media Twitter Support, natürlich jetzt nicht so hundertprozentig ernst gemeint,
ja, aber da ist doch schon was dran, also wenn das wirklich stimmt, dass sie das jetzt
alles gemanagt haben, dass ich echt einen Duels Stack kriege, dann hab ich kein Problem
mit.
Echter Duels Stack, ganz ehrlich, Echter Duels Stack ist mir eh lieber als diese, als
nur IPv4, Echter Duels Stack ist das beste was man haben kann, aber ich hab das denen
eigentlich nicht zugetrauten, ich wollte auf keinen Fall Duels der Kleid, weil Duels
der Kleid einfach der totale Crap ist.
So, ähm, der Woz hat gefragt, Noobfrage, aber wieso ist IPv4 so wichtig?
Kommt auf verschiedene Sachen an, also kommt auf ein paar Sachen an, die du machen willst.
Es gibt zwar jetzt mittlerweile relativ verbreitet IPv6, es gab beispielsweise in manchen Mobilfunknetzen
ne ganze Weile kein IPv6, das ist mittlerweile allerdings gefixt im Endeffekt, aber du brauchst
immer noch, also an IPv4 führt immer noch kein Weg vorbei, also der meiste Traffic wird
immer noch IPv4 sein und es gibt bestimmt auch die einen oder anderen Seiten, die nicht
funktionieren.
Und spätestens, wenn du beispielsweise von einem IPv4, von einem Rechner nur mit IPv4
per VPN zugreifen möchtest, dann musst du ja irgendwie von außen rein mit VPN und das
geht nur, wenn du eine Public IPv4 Adresse hast.
Das ist ein Grund bei mir zum Beispiel, dass ich nicht von außen per VPN bei mir daheim
zugreifen kann, es funktioniert einfach nicht mit Duels der Kleid und Carrier Create NAT,
das ist technisch nicht möglich.
Der andere Punkt ist der umgedrehte Fall, dass du quasi von innen nach außen gehst,
wenn ich beispielsweise VPN auf die Arbeit mache, das hat richtige Probleme mit Carrier
Create NAT.
Ich weiß nicht genau warum, ehrlich gesagt, aber VPN oder auch VoIP ist bekannt dafür,
dass es quasi mit umso mehr NAT-Stufen du hast, umso problematischer wird's.
Und nachdem ich sowohl VoIP als auch VPN auf die Arbeit mache und VPN auf die Arbeit mit
Duels der Kleid das erste Mal schon immer abgekackt ist, will ich das Risiko an der
Stelle schon mal nicht mehr eingehen, weil ich sehe es nicht ein, dass nur weil Unity
Media es nicht auf die Reihe kriegt, dass ich von daheim nichts mehr machen kann.
Ja, klein Rotti, der Twitter Support ist wirklich nicht verkehrt.
Hoffentlich arbeitet hier niemand bei Unity Media, selbst wenn, ganz ehrlich, die können
da wahrscheinlich gar nichts für, also falls jetzt jemand hier ist, ihr könnt da wahrscheinlich
überhaupt nichts für, ihr habt auch eure Vorgaben irgendwie und versucht da ein bisschen
wie bei der Bahn, ihr versucht da wahrscheinlich auch jeden Tag das Beste daraus zu machen.
Hast du einen Tipp oder Vorgehensweise, wie man mit Netzwerken ATC anfängt, den Switch
und Kabel reinstecken, it's easy, easy as fuck, ja angeblich kriege ich ja auch im Laufe
des Tages richtigen Dualstack, damit kann ich auch klingen, ganz ehrlich, ich brauche
kein IPv4, Dualstack ist ein richtiger Dualstack, es ist viel besser, da habe ich richtig IPv4
und IPv6, hast du eigentlich NordVPN, nein, NordVPN sind die, die auf Twitter, auf YouTube
die ganze Zeit Werbung machen, dass man bei ihnen VPN holen soll, nö wozu, wenn ich VPN
mache, dann ist das auch ein VPN oder vielleicht WireGuard, Vertrag telefonisch abgeschlossen,
nö, schriftlich über Twitter, ist das dann unten rechts bei dir ein Aussehen des Winners
Update, ja, und zwar das Kumulativ Update for Windows 10 version 1903, oh bald ist es
wieder soweit oder, kommt nicht bald wieder ein neues Windows Update raus, exo2k, Dankeschön,
Porgas, xJuma hat abonniert, habe ich auch, habe ich auch übersehen und Kaffee mit Salz
auch, Porgas, Dankeschön für die ganzen Abos, Next Level Subs, Big IQ, 1909 ist schon draußen,
na vielleicht kriege ich das zusammen danach, übrigens wisst ihr was richtig nice ist,
dass Windows Updates mittlerweile Vollverschlüsselung unterstützen, die nicht Bitlocker ist, wenn
man Veracrypt seine Platte verschlüsselt hat, kann mittlerweile Windows Updates sogar Veracrypt
Position updaten, der Wout sagt, dass er die großen Updates immer nutzt als Format um
Windows frisch aufzusetzen, warum, Windows muss man nicht frisch aufsetzen, das ist ein
Problem, ich habe mein Windows seit 2 Jahren nicht mehr neu installiert, ich habe das Windows
neu installiert, als ich den Rechner gekauft habe und weil ich das gekauft habe, gibt es
kein Video zu, so Leute, aber bevor ich jetzt wieder ewig lang rumschmetze, also wir haben
das aktuelle runtergeladen für den HC2, ich habe eine SD Karte, ihr wisst ja, ich habe
hier immer noch den Amazon Vorrat an SD Karten, die mir mal, das habe ich euch ja schon erzählt
ein paar mal, dass mir Amazon mal aus Versehen so ein 20er Pack SD Karten geschickt hat,
geht nicht auf, Leute, es geht nicht auf, fuck, wer verpackt diese SD Karten immer ey, was
ist da los, warum gehen SD Karten Gehäuse schwerer auf als irgendwelche Sicherheitsschlösser,
ah, aber wir machen jetzt einfach den Next Level Big Play, wir nehmen eine Schere und
die musstest du nicht zurückschicken, die haben das nicht gemerkt, die haben es nicht
gemerkt und ehrlich gesagt, ich habe da auch kein schlechtes Gewissen, ich habe schon so
viele tausende Euro bei Amazon gelassen und so gut wie nie was zurückgeschickt, die haben
an mir, anteilmäßig, wahrscheinlich gehöre ich in Deutschland zu den, keine Ahnung,
Top 5% Amazon Bestellern oder so, war so viel, wie ich da bestelle, ich bestelle ja seit
15 Jahren oder so, wo sind die SD Karten jetzt hin, habe ich die SD Karten jetzt durchgeschnitten
oder so, ach, da ist sie, ich habe sie, und die haben so viel an mir schon verdient, Amazon,
ich hab wirklich, da habe ich jetzt echt kein schlechtes Gewissen gehabt, wirklich nicht,
so also, flashen wir das ganze mal, connect, virtual machine, bam, in your face, next,
etcher, zack, oh, ich stehe mit dem, mit der Rolle vom Stuhl auf dem Kabel, hat jemand
ein gutes Einsteigerbuch für C-Sharp, jo, habe ich, sogar kostenlos, das da, das hier,
kostenlos, gutes Buch, so bis, bis Kapitel 16, den Rest brauchst du nicht unbedingt,
bis Kapitel 16, das ist zwar 2012, aber von den Basics her macht das keinen großen Unterschied,
hier, wenn du das gelesen hast und verstanden hast, bis Kapitel 16, kannst du ordentlich
programmieren, warum macht da eigentlich die Hintergrund von den Bildern nicht auch dunkel?
So, hydrant, verschenkt ein Stufe 1 Abo, und zwar, wer hat's bekommen, der Eric, 1303,
äh, 1803, hört sich an wie ne Windows 10 Version, äh, dankeschön für den Sub, ne,
nicht, nicht, nicht Prime, nicht, nicht Prime, normaler Sub, ja, also das Buch kann ich dir
empfehlen hier, nimm das, für den Einstieg, top, und ansonsten, es war grad.NET Conf,
da findest du aktuelle Themen, Themen, die Webcasts, die Builds sind auch immer gut,
übrigens, ihr müsst mich mal ein bisschen flamen, wenn ich, ähm, irgendwie Subs vergesse
oder so, wenn ich konzentriert bin, passiert das manchmal, ok, ähm, Edger, zack, Downloads,
das Image, auf die 32 GSD-Karte, flaschen, bam, babam, auf geht's, ey, was geht, scheise
Dreck, bester Name, ey, hab ich heut schon, hab ich heut schon im Discord gesehen, scheise
Dreck, was hältst du von IOS Dark Mode, beste, hab ich, hab ich, das, IOS Dark Mode war das
erste, was ich aktiviert hab nach dem Update, 11 Cent Powerplant, huge, ne, 2x1, oder, 2
Cent, poggers, was heißt flaschen, ähm, die Firmen austauschen, oder, sag mal, sag
mal, ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz für die Noobs gesagt, du tauschst das Betriebssystem aus,
was auf dem jeweiligen Gerät drauf ist, durch ein anderes, flaschen, ja gut, diese Sorte
von Flaschen meinte ich jetzt nicht, als Abenteurer, du kannst in deiner IDE machen, was du lustig
bist, aber Dark Mode ist das beste, endlich haben sie mal was gescheites gemacht bei Apple,
ich hab übrigens immer noch nicht auf mein iPhone 11, äh, nicht 11, XR umgestellt, ne,
das liegt jetzt seit einem Monat oder so schon im Karton neben mir hier, ich hab's immer
noch nicht umgebaut, ich will diesen fetten Klotz auch gar nicht, ich weiß, das sind
massive First World Problems, alle würden sich vielleicht freuen, wenn sie so ein iPhone
hätten, aber ich finde das 6er echt nicht schlecht, alles was größer ist als ein 6er
kann ich nicht gescheit mit einer Hand bedienen, das ist übertrieben easy, ich weiß, ich weiß,
ich weiß, dass das übertrieben easy ist, ich mach einfach Cloud Backup, da brauch ich ja
nicht mal die kack iTunes, wieso hast du nicht das 8er genommen, weil das von der Firma ist,
wo ich arbeite, ich kann mir das nicht aussuchen, auch wenn ich's mir gerne ausgesucht hätte,
oder?
Übrigens, hab ich euch jetzt erzählt, wir haben auch letztens im Stream geguckt, ob ich,
wo's günstig einen Apple SE, einen iPhone SE gibt, ich hab jetzt auf eBay einen China
Anbieter gefunden und hab mir für 100 Euro einen Apple SE bestellt, also mit Versandkosten
100 Euro irgendwie im Dreh, ist jetzt angekommen, stand da zwar drinne als neu, jaja Moment,
Moment, es stand da zwar als neu drinne, aber als ich die Packung aufgemacht hab, das erste
was ich gesehen hab, ist, dass das kein Original Apple Karton ist, also das war gar kein Karton,
das war in so dieser komischen Folie, die so ploppt eingewickelt und wenn du das im Licht
geguckt hast, so im Spiegel, das im Licht, hast du gesehen, das hatte schon minimale
Gebrauchsspuren, also das ist jetzt nicht so, dass es tiefe Kratzer hat, aber du hast schon
gesehen, dass da mal ein paar Leute drüber gewischt haben oben und so, also es stand
zwar als neu drinne, aber in aller Bedeutung der Tatsache, dass quasi 90 Euro plus Versand
quasi für einen Apple SE auch gebraucht, echt gar nicht so schlecht sind, wie es in
dem Zustand ist, werd ich das behalten.
Scamars, ja der China-Mann hat uns gestern schon Scamars, da hatte er mich eigentlich
wieder Scamars, so also den USB-Stick, zieh den jetzt mal raus, so jetzt nehm ich die
Micro SD-Karte und stöpsel das Ganze mal in unseren Odroid rein und dann gucken wir
mal ob das Ganze funktioniert, schauen wir mal ne, also zack, Netzwerkkabel, Netzwerkkabel
dran und Strom dran, oh fuck ist das jetzt, äh Moment, was für Netzteil braucht das
Ding, ich wollt da grad irgendwie nen Netzteil ranstecken, das wär ganz schnell RIP geworden,
was brauchen das überhaupt für Netzteil, was braucht das für Netzteil, wo steht,
hier, Any, 5, 9, 15, was, 12, ja das ist ein 12 Volt Netzteil was ich hab, das ist ok,
das passt, sonst hätt's gleich, sonst hätt's gleich hier MonkaS smoked, wenn ich das angeschlossen
hätte.
Ok, ich stöpsel das jetzt mal rein und dann schau ich ob's startet und wir melden uns
PSSH an und gucken was da los ist auf dem Ding, zack, es geht an und es raucht auch nicht,
das ist schon mal ganz gut, ah, guck ich mal nebenbei auf meinem Rauder, was das Ding für
ne, was das Ding für ne IP gekriegt hat, Aquarium Livecam, ja in Wirklichkeit ist
das Aquarium Webcam, da ist allerdings ein ASCII Filter drüber, also ich mach quasi
Webcam to ASCII und das zeige ich euch dann, das letzte Mal grillen dieses Jahr, ich glaube
das letzte Mal grillen, war bei mir das letzte Mal grillen, ohne dass mir bewusst war, dass
es das letzte Mal grillen war, weil das ist jetzt schon ein paar Monate her und ich werd
dieses Jahr nicht mal grillen.
Welchen Router hast du noch mal fürs Heimnetz, Hex, Hex, Mikrotik Hex PoE, ähm, Idea, brauchst
du wirklich nen Router oder willst du einfach nur nen Switch, weil ich verstehe nicht was
das mit deinem Nass zu tun hat, ok, angeblich haben wir, ah, da isser, SSH, BAM, Host Verification
Feld, RIP, ok, yes, äh, wenn ich jetzt das Default Passwort wüsste, wahrscheinlich
Odroid, Odroid oder so, Root, Odroid, Root, Odroid, POK, funktioniert.
Ok, erstmal updaten, zack, Hex Source, Massive Hex Source, irgendwie, das ist doch nicht mein
normaler Font, das ist doch im Leben nicht mein normaler Font, das ist mein normaler
Font, angeblich ist das der gleiche Font, aber das ist, das ist doch offensichtlich
ein anderer Font als das hier, guckt mal, das ist offensichtlich ein anderer Font, obwohl
er sagt es wäre der gleiche Font, ich hätte zwar keine Ahnung was mit dem Ding los ist,
aber das ist ein anderer Font, oder, bin ich einfach nur dumm, ich bin einfach nur dumm,
oder, wobei, nee, das muss ein anderer Font sein, sieht mir auch schon, dass die Leiste
unten nicht mehr passt. Lass mal das größere an, so, komisch.
Ok, passt so, perfekt, so ist schön, wenn ihr das gut seht, nice. So, jetzt haben wir
geupdatet, upgraden müssen wir noch, yes, ok, die Installation ist immer easy, jetzt
müssen wir mal gucken, bei Linux TV, das ist ein ganz gutes Wiki zu TV Sticks, ab wann
was unterstützt wird, das Doodle ist anstrengend, ja, das Doodle ist echt anstrengend, dachte
mir eigentlich, dass Non-Vocal ganz angenehm ist, aber ist es nicht, wir machen lieber
wieder unsere entspannten Wub Wub Wub an, viel besser, oder, viel besser entspannter
Wub Wub, ja, oder, Achtung Sonnenbrille aufsetzen, ja, so ist das gut, so, Linux TV, Wind TV,
Dual HD nennt sich das Ding, das Ding, so, wir müssen jetzt mal gucken, wie das unterstützt
wird, weil es könnte ja sein, dass ich einen TV Stick gekauft habe, der gar nicht richtig
läuft unter Linux, aber ich hab, ich bilde mir einen, ich hab nachgeguckt und das wurde
unterstützt, Dual Tuner, bla bla bla, es gibt zwei verschiedene Modelle, Modell 01590,
Modell 1595, was auch immer, ab wann wird das ganze unterstützt, Making It Work, bla
bla bla, Firmware, Only First Tuner Model, ok, Kernel 47, das ist uralt, Kernel 411,
ok, easy, das haben wir, was haben wir denn für einen Kernel, 414, ja, dann ist kein
Ding, ok, also wir haben, unser Kernel ist neu genug, wir haben 414 auf jeden Fall unterstützt,
dann würde ich sagen, wir installieren jetzt erstmal so die wichtigsten Sachen, die wir
brauchen, wir brauchen einen Wim, wir brauchen einen T-Max, wir brauchen einen Hardtop, wir
brauchen einen De-Stat und wir brauchen, weiß ich nicht, also ne, Text Editor, Terminal
Multiplexer, Prozessor Auslastung und IO, könntest du mal eine CTF Hacking Challenge
on Stream, weiß ich nicht, ob ich das auf die Reihe krieg, wir können aber mal die BSI
Hacking Challenge machen, die ist zumindest, zumindest die erste Stufe ist ziemlich einfach,
Michael 50 Milliarden, das ist nice, dass dir trotzdem gefällt, Hardtop beste, ja, seh
ich auch so, T-Max, Wim, Hardtop brauchst du auf jeder Linux Kiste, wegen mir könnte
das auch Standard sein, dass überall T-Max und Hardtop dabei ist, T-Max brauchen wir
hier, dass man die Session zumachen kann, das läuft trotzdem noch weiter und Hardtop
brauchen wir für die Auslastung, wir sehen, diese kleine Kiste hat 8 CPU Kerne, was ist
T-Max, T-Max ist quasi ein Tiling Window Manager für die Konsole, also du kannst zum
Beispiel damit verschiedene Splits aufmachen, in dem einen Split lässt du das hier laufen,
in dem anderen Split lässt du das hier laufen und hier oben machst du irgendwas, was ist
T-Max, und das schöne daran ist, ja deswegen, ich hab ja Terminal Multiplexer gesagt, aber
ganz ehrlich, kein Mensch, der fragt, was ist T-Max, kann mit Terminal Multiplexer was
anfangen, kein Mensch versteht, was ein Terminal Multiplexer ist, wenn er nicht weiß, was
er, das ist ein ziemlich bescheuerter Begriff, mag es zwar technisch treffen, aber so wirklich
sagen tut es keinem was, hallo Max, was ist dein Main Betriebssystem, Windows 10, ja,
Windows 10 forever Workstation für Linux, so und das schöne an T-Max ist, wenn man jetzt
zum Beispiel hier was laufen hat im Hintergrund und man macht sein Fenster zu, so RIP, oh nein,
mein Rechner ist abgestürzt, normalerweise hätte man jetzt ja das Problem, jetzt stimmt
die Schrift, ok ich hab keine Ahnung was da geht, da hätte man jetzt ja das Problem,
dass jetzt der SSH Verbindung abgebrochen wäre und dass der Befehl, der im Hintergrund
auf dem Server läuft, nicht mehr ausgefüllt wird, aber nicht so, wenn man das Ganze in
T-Max gestartet hat, da Attach man sich einfach wieder und siehe da, der Kram ist im Hintergrund
weiter gelaufen, deswegen, wenn man länger laufende Sachen auf dem Server macht, immer
in einem T-Max starten, am besten einfach immer in einem T-Max starten, wenn man auf
dem Server geht, dann vergisst man es nicht mehr, einfach ins SSH schon mit rein, dass
es standardmäßig startet, was ist das für ein Odroid, ein HC2, dieses Nass für Arme,
das da, Screen T-Max, hör mal auf, Screen ist sowas von 1990, der einzigen Vorteil
den Screen hat ist Session Sharing, um bei das mit T-Max auch ganz gut geht, hast du
nicht schon einmal am Juiced Shop Projekt versucht? Nö, ich weiß gar nicht was das
ist, am neuen Ubuntu ist Hardtop und T-Max, ja zum Glück, ja da nicht, das ist aber Ubuntu
Minimal, so, jetzt haben wir das installiert, was muss man als nächstes machen? Leute,
ich darf mich nicht so sehr sidetracken lassen, wir schließen jetzt die TV-Karte an und gucken
ob alles erkannt wird, das machen wir jetzt, easy, das machen wir jetzt, das ist auf jeden
Fall schon mal sinnvoller Geschichte, weil wenn die TV-Karte nicht erkannt wird, muss
ich gar nicht erst weitermachen, ok die TV-Karte leuchtet schon mal, blöd, da ist sie, nee,
das ist der Airport für die Fernbedienung, DVB, das sieht schon sehr nach TV-Karte aus
ehrlich gesagt, hier, Identified as, äh, äh, Dings, ich weiß nicht wie man die ausspricht,
man spricht sie definitiv nicht Hauptauge aus, äh, Wind TV, ok, da hat das ganze schon
mal erkannt, äh, wo ist der DVB-C-Tuner, seht ihr irgendwie einen an den DVB-C-Tuner,
hier, DVB, Blah, Zeug, wird schon funktionieren, Hauptauge, nein das glaube ich nicht, dass
man die so ausspricht, was war das jetzt für ein Befehl, äh, das da, das ist Kernlock,
also ich habe keine Ahnung ob man das offiziell Kernlock nennt ehrlich gesagt, ja doch Kernlock,
also das was der Kern so treibt, da stehen Fehler drin, also das ist eigentlich das wichtigste
Lock auf jedem Linux-System, das da, die Kern-Messages, da siehst du Fehler drin, da siehst du beispielsweise
wenn irgendein Fallsystem nicht only ist oder wenn irgendwie, dass der Kern rum meint, es
backt irgendwas rum, du siehst neue Geräte, es gibt für alles andere auch, äh, ordentliche
Befehle, aber immer wenn ich was anstöpsel, das erste was ich mache ist ein D-Mask, um
hinten dran zu gucken, was ist, was ist denn passiert, was ist denn angestöpselt, das ist
natürlich für Windows-User, ist das hier der blanke Horror, ja, die kriegen immer
absolut Zustände wenn die das sehen, die denken sich nach dem Motto, mein Gott, ich
muss in einen Text, ich muss in ein Terminal um rauszukriegen was angeschlossen wurde
an mein Rechner, oh nein, ja, mein Gehirn explodiert, das halte ich nicht aus, dabei
ist die Ausgabe viel besser als in irgendeinem Kackgeräte-Manager gucken oder so, so, TV-Karte
ist anscheinend erkannt, ähm, was muss man jetzt machen, TV-Header installiert oder,
habe ich noch irgendwas vergessen, irgendeinen Zwischenschritt, äh, wie kann man sehen,
welche Geräte LS-USB kannst du machen, LS-USB oder Minus-T war es für Tree, LS-USB siehst
du was angeschlossen ist oder alternativ LS-PCI, äh, PSCI, ok, was, ah, da sehe ich
gerade schon mal eine Sache, äh, wenn das nicht installiert ist, es kann sich nämlich
beispielsweise, also ich kann mir nicht merken in welchen, in welchen Paketen diese Sachen
drinne installiert sind, deswegen gibt es ein super, ein super, ähm, ein super Tool,
was man eigentlich immer installiert haben sollte, nämlich Command Not Found, das heißt
so, und guck, und gucken, dass die Bash-Completions auch alle installiert sind, und ich zeige
euch gleich mal was passiert, wenn ich den Kram installiert habe, WTF, wie hast du dich
in den Linus-Kernel eingelesen, habe ich gar nicht, null, ich glaube von dem C-Code verstehe
ich wahrscheinlich nur die Hälfte, oder, oder, 10%, gar nicht, gar nicht, ich verstehe
ein bisschen die Ausgaben, die in dem, die im Log drinne stehen, ja, und das erste was
man verstehen muss, ist, dass die meisten Ausgaben hier drinne vollkommen irrelevant sind für
den täglichen Betrieb, wenn man sich das hier nämlich mal anguckt, das ist alles irgendwelche
Boot-Messages, was er gefunden hat, bla, blub, juck, kein, aber, wenn man, wenn man
weiß, dass man jetzt was angestöpselt hat, und man weiß ja auch, was man ungefähr angestöpselt
hat, und man guckt dann in die Kernel-Messages rein, und sieht, aha, er hat irgendwelche,
irgendwelche DVB-Dingsbums-Adapter erkannt, na dann wird's ja wohl, und sogar der Name,
na dann wird's ja wohl der TV-Stick sein, den ich, den ich angeschlossen habe, ok,
und was meinen die jetzt, kann man hier nachgucken, haben wir net, ok, dann gucken wir mal mit
LS-USB, was wir haben, wow, so, das sind die Infos zu unserem TV-Stick, der sagt immer
noch, das ist im Prinzip auch alles ziemlich wurscht, der sagt, das ist ein Hauptauge,
was auch immer, Dual-HD passt ja, Max-Power, 50mAh, 500mAh, wen juckts, das ist im Prinzip
alles wurscht, was da steht, das interessiert mich jetzt nicht, er hat das Ding erkannt,
und er hat anscheinend auch Treiber dafür geladen, weil ansonsten, würden hier nicht
solche Devices angezeigt, wir können mal gucken, ob er wirklich Treiber geladen hat, wir können
gucken, oder Dev-DVB-Adapter, genau, das sind so Sachen, das lernt man mit der Zeit, wo
irgendwie was, für irgendwas steht, ich glaube, die spreche ich hapaq aus, hapaq, ok, hapaq,
nicht Hauptauge, hapaq, aber das ist ein TV-Stick, den hat er erkannt, so, genau, jetzt wollte
ich euch ja, wollte ich euch noch was zeigen, und zwar, wir haben hier oben probiert LS-PCI
zu machen, das ging nicht, jetzt habe ich allerdings Command-Not-Found installiert, ich muss mich
noch erstmal neu verbinden, jetzt habe ich Command-Not-Found installiert, wenn ich jetzt
LS-PCI mache, sagt er mir, Command-Not-Found, but can be installed, der guckt dann für
mich nach im Hintergrund, welches Paket ich installieren muss, und das ist enorm praktisch,
also Bash-Completion und Command-Not-Found ist das, eines der ersten Sachen, die ich
auch noch nach Hardtop mit installiere, ich meine, man kann das natürlich selbst alles
rauskriegen mit Abt, aber so ist es viel angenehmer, so, und dadurch, dass man die Standard, die
Standard Bash-Completion installiert hat, kann ich jetzt auch sowas machen, install,
zum Beispiel net, tap-tap, und ich sehe, was für Pakete gibt, die mit net anfangen, zum
Beispiel, ah, guckt, net-stat ist nicht drauf, net, jetzt muss ich net-tools installieren,
install, mache ich einfach so, net-tools-tap, zack, und solche Sachen sind es, die dafür
sorgen, dass Windows-User zu Unrecht Angst haben vor Terminals, Windows-User sollten Angst
haben vor der Windows-CMD, aber nicht vor einem ordentlichen Terminal mit ordentlicher
Shell, gibt es das auch auf Arch, klar, klar, gibt es das, alles klar, so, net-stat wird
jetzt nicht so aussagekräftig sein, net-stat-Tulpen kann man sich auch gut merken, TCP, UDP, Listen,
Port und No-Reverse-Lockup, glaube ich, nagelt mich jetzt nicht so, wer fährt drauf fest,
für was Tulpen steht, man kann auch Tulpen machen, kann man sich besser merken, schon
mal mit der Windows 10 Ubuntu Shell gespielt, ja, ist ganz brauchbar, sogar mit dem neuen
Terminal, es wird besser, es wird besser, ein paar Sachen gehen halt immer noch nicht
gescheit, zum Beispiel irgendwelche Samba-Sachen, Mountain oder generell Fallsysteme, aber es
ist auf jeden Fall deutlich angenehmer wie CMD oder PowerShell, weil PowerShell an sich
gut ist, aber PowerShell ist keine gute Admin-Shell, sondern eine gute Scripting-Shell, man könnte
sagen, PowerShell ist im Vergleich zur Bash oder zu ZSH die bessere Scripting-Automatisierung-Shell,
allerdings Bash und ZSH, oder meinetwegen auch FISH, ist auf jeden Fall die bessere
Admin-Shell als PowerShell, also es ist nicht alle schlecht, was Microsoft da so treibt,
ja, man kann sogar PowerShell oder Linux installieren, so, jetzt lassen wir mal Big Brain, Leute,
was müssen wir jetzt eigentlich machen, der TV-Adapter funktioniert, wir installieren
jetzt einfach mal W-Scan, W-Scan ist ein Kommando-Zeiten-Tool, wo man TV-Channels mit scannen kann, also
ich weiß, dass es nicht funktionieren kann, weil ich hab ja überhaupt kein Kabel an, wie
nennt man das, am Kabelanschluss, ja, also der TV-Stick hat kein Kabel drin, das kann
nicht funktionieren, aber ich will sehen, ob das Scannen an sich funktioniert, so, Scanning,
DVB-T, nein, es scannt DVB-T, das ist falsch, wir wollen, wir wollen, Type-Cable wollen
wir haben, ne, F, F was, F oder T, F, ne, F für Type, ist doch voll logisch, oder, finde
das F in Type, ah, Frontend, Frontend-Type, ok, ja, verstehe, ok, ok, das Scannen scheint
zu funktionieren, very good, also Scannen von TV-Channels funktioniert, das lassen wir
jetzt nicht durchlaufen, weil das dauert, das heißt, der Stick wird wohl erkannt und
es tut, das heißt, wir können als nächstes, das funktioniert viel zu einfach, sag ich
euch, da muss doch irgendwas passieren jetzt, wir können als TV-Header installieren, streamst
du auch Live-Coding, ja, ab und zu mal, hauptsächlich C-Sharp und ein bisschen Web-Frontend-Gedöns
in letzter Zeit, C-Sharp-Backend, Vue.js-Frontend, ja, da ist gar kein TV-Header drauf, haben
wir überhaupt Kodi installiert, haben wir Kodi installiert auf unserem Arch, weil Kodi
brauchen wir, ohne Kodi ist doof, da können wir später nicht testen, ob das Fernsehen
funktioniert, kannst ja mal im Archiv gucken, da müssten ein paar Coding-Sachen drin sein,
ich weiß nicht, ob ich in den letzten paar Wochen programmiert hab on stream, aber du
kannst im Archiv gucken, mach mal Ausrufezeichen Archiv, da sind die ganzen ollen Webcast drin,
nee, ich benutze Joghurt, bis Joghurt nicht mehr geht, wie ist eigentlich deine Meinung
zu Fedora, ja, wenn man auf RPM-Sachen steht und unbedingt ein Desktop-RPM-System haben
will, da bleibt ja nur so wirklich Fedora, nee, Basuse, so, hat er Kodi installiert?
Kodra, perfekt, Exit, welche Kodi-Version waren das überhaupt, das war schon 18, oder?
18, ja, gut, achso, und Kodi-TV-Headend brauchen wir noch, Kodi-PvP, den da brauchen wir noch,
dass wir uns überhaupt dann verbinden können zum Server, ihh, was ist das alles, Package
Found, fuck, okay, ich hab keine Ahnung, was er da als alles installiert, ehrlich gesagt,
aber wir lassen ihn, wir lassen ihn mal installieren, oh, jetzt werden irgendwelche Repos geklont,
irgendwelche Sachen kombiniert und so, mal gucken, ob alles funktioniert, Magic, nee,
ich hab die Dot-Files, hab ich nicht, Public, aber wenn du was Spezielles wissen willst,
können wir nachgucken, okay, hat anscheinend funktioniert, easy, gut, dann können wir
jetzt hier TV-Headend installieren, dazu gehen wir mal, uns die offiziellen Abt-Repos raussuchen,
weil ich weiß, dass die Abt-Repos haben, hier, Bionic, Ubuntu 1804 haben wir, Install-Repos,
okay, da, Blum, das da, dann den Key importieren, alles klar, ich weiß, dass ich Joghurt nicht
mehr benutzen soll, aber ich hab mich da so dran gewöhnt, das ist, so, und jetzt brauchen
wir hier Sources-List für Stable, jawoll, mal update und gucken, ob wir das installiert
bekommen, hat viele sicher, ja, ich weiß, dass ich es nicht mehr verwenden soll, oh,
was Tritzen geht genau so, was Tritzen, installier ich mal, muss ich mal ausprobieren, wow, Pearl,
geht, muss ich jetzt echt Pearl installieren dafür, okay, ich verschiebe das mal auffallend,
oh, die haben keine Arm-Packages für TV-Head-End, das ist aber doof, warum haben die keine Arm-Packages,
TV-End läuft auch auf dem Raspberry auf, warum haben die keine Arm-Packages, ja, Distro,
scheiße, die haben nur 64, also nur x86, also das jetzt selbst zu kompilieren habe ich
ehrlich gesagt nicht so wahnsinnig viel bock drauf, ah, guck mal, for Arm-C here, da hat
eine Arm-Package das dran gehängt, ne, ich will das nicht selber kompilieren, habe ich
echt keinen bock drauf, gibt es nicht irgendwas, Fernt, unofficial, für was steht denn ppa
eins, das sind quasi die Ubuntu User-Repos, aber ich weiß nicht wofür das steht, so,
AMD 64, das brauchen wir, das brauchen wir, jawoll, big brain, da können wir nämlich
den Kram wieder löschen, den Kram den wir hinzugefügt haben, den löschen wir jetzt
einfach wieder, so, und fügen dieses Ubuntu-Repo hinzu, personal-package-archive, aha, und
dann installieren wir das eben hier draus, ist auch ok, kann ich auch mitleben, update,
search, so, was haben wir da für eine Version drin, 4.29, das ist glaube ich das aktuellste,
oder, TV-Head-End-Version, was ist das aktuellste, hier, ja, 4.29 passt, wo ist denn jetzt, meine
VM ist RIP, sehe ich das richtig, meine VM ist RIP, hm, ah, ok, was auch immer, es geht
wieder, install, TV-Head-End, wow, ok, der will 3 Milliarden Sachen installieren, aber
ich installiere das wahrscheinlich einfach, ich meine, scheiß drauf, so ein paar Kilobyte
mehr Abhängigkeiten, ja, außerdem interessiert es mich überhaupt nicht, ob das ein Perl ist,
es könnte meinetwegen sogar in Java programmiert sein, wenn mir egal, solange es funktioniert,
wobei, na, bei Java bin ich mir nicht ganz so sicher, admin-name, admin, Passwort, huge
brain, Passwort, 123456, so, accessport, 9981, sehr schön, so, er installiert, kurze Frage
an den Chat, Wim oder Emacs, ich würde heutzutage das gar nicht mehr großartig vergleichen,
weil Emacs mittlerweile immer weniger Anhänger hat und immer weniger aktualisierte Sachen
und die generell, die ganze Community und Entwicklung ziemlich langsam geworden ist
bei Emacs, ich habe früher selbst Emacs verwendet, mittlerweile verwende ich Wim für kleine Sachen
oder VS Code, wenn es komplexere Sachen braucht, Emacs hat echt Potenzial und war ja auch saumäßig
beliebt über fast Jahrzehnte, könnte man sagen, aber es ist auf dem absteigenden Ast, dumme
Frage, wer schaut heutzutage noch Fernsehen, meine Mutter, ich nicht, Nano ist crap, Boomer
schauen auf Fernsehen, only Boomer, bei mir gehts bloß noch Prime Video, YouTube und Twitch,
fertig, ja brauchste, weil die will Fernsehen gucken und als Frontend ist das ein Shield
TV und ein Shield TV konnte die ganze Zeit kein Fernseh empfangen, mittlerweile haben
sie limitierten Tuner Support, allerdings mit Kodi schon mal gar nicht, ansonsten brauchst
ein TV Sauber, entweder installierst du den TV Sauber mit auf dem Shield TV, was da aber
andere Probleme bringt oder du stellst eine extra Kiste daneben, die das macht, weil normalerweise
würde ich sagen, nehm diese komische Unity Media Kiste und guck damit Fernsehen, aber
es ist halt kein Shield TV, sag mal so, wenn du einmal so ne Android TV Box die halbwegs
schnell verwendet hast, willst du eigentlich nix anderes mehr, das ist wirklich praktisch,
das ist wirklich praktisch, also wenn man wirklich mal ne Android TV hatte, willst du eigentlich
keine Horizon Box oder so n Crap haben, inwiefern ist die Box dann praktisch gar nicht, bei
mir ist die Horizon Box noch in der Packung und bleibt es auch, wir haben TV BC, doch
doch Kabel, ok TV Head ist installiert, dann machen wir mal Netz, und sehen das ganze läuft
auf Port 9981, dazu gibt es eigentlich nur zu sagen, wo ist mein Nice, da, erkennt Cody
den DVBC Stick mittlerweile nicht selbst per USB, nö, oder vielleicht, kann sein, aber
dann muss Cody die Sache immer noch aufnehmen, ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, ob das
mittlerweile Cody direkt kann, achso ne ich mein, inwiefern ist die Android Version praktischer,
du meinst was der Vorteil von Android TV gegenüber der Horizon Box ist, ne allein schon der ganze
App Store, dass du nen ordentlichen Browser auf der Kiste hast, dass du nen ordentlichen
Plex Client hast, dass du im Prinzip alles hast was Android hast, was du auf der Horizon
Box nicht hast, auf der Horizon Box kannst du wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal Amazon gucken,
ich weiß nicht was du da alles drauf machen kannst, zumindest willst du definitiv keinen
ordentlichen brauchbaren Browser haben, und auf dem Shield TV hast du einfach alles, alles
was du haben willst, weil es halt ein ordentliches Android ist, du kannst es vor allem auch richtig
gut in Automatisierung einbinden, ich hab es so gemacht, dass zum Beispiel, wenn die Klingel
geht bzw. das Telefon klingelt oder die Hoftür geöffnet wird, dann kommt ne Popup Benachrichtigung
mit dem was gerade ist, auf dem Fernseh, über meine Heimautomatisierung an Cody, und wenn
das Telefon geht bzw. die Tür, dann pausiert er sogar den Fernseh, und wenn man das Telefon
wieder auflegt, wartet er 30 Sekunden und macht dann Time Shift, Fernsehprogramm an,
und wenn du das Telefon wieder auflegst, nach 30 Sekunden macht der Fernsehmeter automatisch
Resume, das ist Next Level Shit oder?
Also Live TV mit Plex war das letzte Mal, als ich geguckt hab, nicht sonderlich schön,
das war mit TV hätte ein deutlich angenehmer, ja kann Cody mittlerweile selbst?
Kann Cody das mittlerweile selbst?
Cody hat ja keine Treiber so wirklich dabei, das ist ja nur Aufsatz.
Wie die Performance von dem Stick ist, das können wir uns gleich mal angucken zusammen.
Na ich glaube also über TV hätte ein dürfte, das ist immer noch deutlich angenehmer sein,
da kannst du Aufnahmen, Schedule und alles mögliche.
Ok dann gehen wir mal auf TV hätte ein drauf, 9 und 8, 1 war es, Admin, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
Sound Save, so, Language, Englisch, Next, was ist jetzt für ein Problem, Next, Allowed
Networks, alle, Admin, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, User, TV, Headend, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, Huge Passwords
heute angesagt, Tuner-Type machen wir später, Next, Next, Next, Finish, ok Leute, gucken
wir mal ob der Stick funktioniert, Altyris, Igitt, hör mal auf, Altyris hatten wir vor
14 Jahren oder so mal für Windows Server aufgebaut, das war schrecklich, Leute fällt euch was
auf, Big Brain Frage Chat, was stimmt hier dran nicht an der Anzeige oder was ist an
der Anzeige anders als erwartet, es heißt nicht Hauptauge, ne, das Problem ist, das
sollte ein Dual-Tuner sein, und das ist kein Dual-Tuner, das ist ein Single DVB-T-Tuner
und ein Single DVB-T-Tuner und ein Single DVB-C-Tuner, ich brauch aber ein Dual-Tuner, nein, nein,
nein, nein, das ist nicht Dual, ja also, ja es ist Dual, es ist einmal DVB-T und einmal
DVB-C, aber es sind, es sind Dual-Tuner, also es müssten zwei DVB-C-Tuner sein und zwei
DVB-T-Tuner sein, guckt, das sagen die sogar, ja, Dual-Tuner, gleichzeitig Fernsehen aufnehmen,
DVB-T-HD, DVB-C-HD, die Dings, ja, Dual-HD, Dual-Tuner, zwei Programme gleichzeitig aufnehmen,
Fang-Häkchen, DVB-C-Häkchen, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee,
nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee,
nee, nee, nee, nee, nee.
nur noch einen store ein betriebssystem in verschiedenen ausführungen und eine programmiersprache nutzen würden warum
das wäre dann für jegliche innovation kacke
also ich glaube ich glaube noch nicht guck mal sie können einen sender schauen während gleichzeitig ein anderer sender aufgezeichnet
dass das ist nicht das meinen die nicht so die wie man kann damit auf jeden fall doppelt dvbc und und
es wäre aber hartko irreführend oder
das glaube ich
was
lutz key zu hast du das schon mal ausprobiert kann man in kodi wenn man das mit dem mit der mit
diesem fritz repeater macht kann man dann in kodi auch aufnehmen beziehungsweise serien aufnahmen
machen und sowas?
Welche Linux-Distribution empfiehlst du, wenn man sich schon etwas mit Linux auskennt
und ein möglichst ressourcensparendes, effizientes OS möchte?
Ja, das gleiche wie der Chat sagt, allerdings würde ich Manjaro verwenden, weil ich finde
Manjaro ist einfach die benutzerfreundliche Artstellungsvariante, die es nicht ganz so
Oh, oh, ups, seht ihr das?
Die beiden Tuner sind erst ab Kernel 4.17 supportet und wir haben Kernel 4.14
Gibt es dafür neuere Kernel?
Kernel 4.17
Kernel 4.7 Image Available, ja genau das brauchen wir
We provide 5.1 ist auch okay
Okay, ich soll ein anderes Betriebssystem installieren
Gibt kein Ubuntu 19 für die Kiste
Naja, den Kernel kann man insofern nicht updaten, weil das wahrscheinlich
der aktuellste Kernel ist vom
Fuck, wie heißt der Firmware, ne wie heißt der Kernel nochmal, der Kernel heißt irgendwie nicht Kernel
Oh, das bringt mir nichts, das ist Ubuntu ja, aber Leute das bringt mir nichts, ich brauche
Arm, ich brauche Ultroid, Ultroid Arm Kernels
Was ist das Ziel, meine TV Karte zum, okay fort, meine TV Karte zum Laufen zu bringen
Mit beiden Tunern
Okay, es hat doch bestimmt irgendwie einen Fünfer Kernel, hier Kernel 5 Development Thread, easy
Wir kompilieren uns jetzt einfach in einen Kernel, auf gehts, bam
Was von 2017, the fuck
Fünf, ja jetzt wird Kernel kompiliert, auf gehts, März 20, perfekt
Auf gehts
Wir müssen mal ein bisschen den Thread hier lesen, gibt es hier fertige Images oder so
Wir müssen mal kurz gucken, ob es hier fertige Images gibt
Das ist jetzt nicht euer Ernst oder, hallo, kann das mal laden
Okay, 50RC2, ich will eigentlich, ich habe eigentlich keinen Bock da als ein Kernel zu kompilieren, na egal
Images, wo gibt es ein Image, da musst du irgendeine Image gebaut haben
Das bringt mir alles nichts Flixcoder, ich brauche einen Kernel, der das Ding unterstützt und zwar mit Ultroid Patches für Arm
Nee, nee, Kelmore, das ist, der meint damit, dass es der Ultroid XU4 ist mit dem 50 irgendwas Kernel
Oh, was ist das hier, Download Seite, nee das ist die offizielle Linux Seite
Perfect, das ist genau das Richtige für uns, huge
Kannst du nicht einfach den Kernel upgraden, nee, es gibt keinen offiziell neueren Kernel
Wir brauchen eine welche mit Ultroid Patches und für Arm, Ubuntu 1804 x86 hat einen 5er Kernel neuerdings dabei
Aber es bringt ja nichts 86er, offizieller x86er Ubuntu Kernel bringt uns ja nichts
Wir brauchen nicht nur einen Armkernel, wir brauchen einen Armkernel mit Ultroid Patches, dass es richtig funktioniert
Okay, jetzt wird erstmal ein Linux Git geklaut, Leute wir sehen uns in 3 Stunden wieder
Naja geht doch, also ich schätze mal, das Ding hat wirklich Wumms
Nachdem man auf einem aktuellen Desktop einen Linux Kernel ungefähr, ich sag mal in 5 bis 10 Minuten kompiliert
Oder in 5 Minuten, in 5 Minuten kompilierst du es, eigentlich unter 5 Minuten
Kompilierst du einen Linux Kernel auf einem aktuellen Desktop Rechner
Würde ich mal sagen, wir brauchen hier wahrscheinlich 20 Minuten oder so, 40 Minuten vielleicht
Ach hier guck mal, also Leute, freut euch schon mal auf 30 Minuten Kernel kompilieren
In der Zeit können wir was anderes machen während der Kernel kompiliert, da müssen wir ja nicht zugucken
Kannst du das nicht einfach auf dem Desktop kompilieren? Doch, theoretisch schon
Allerdings habe ich keine Ahnung, wie ich den Kernel für Ultroid cross-compile auf meinem Desktop
Was verwendest du vor allem, das ist VirtualBox, äh nicht VirtualBox, vor allem der Workstation
VirtualBox, Alter
Also das Repo-Klonen von Linux geht schon mal wahnsinnig schneller
Was wird denn hier gutes gekocht? Wir müssen uns jetzt einen 5er Kernel kompilieren
Für ARM mit Ultroid Patches, dass meine TV-Karte funktioniert
Das ist echt mal Next Level Shit, oder?
Aber das coole Unterliegen ist es mal wieder, es funktioniert
Okay, weiter geht's, seine Kernel-Config, bam, ich mach jetzt einfach die Anleitung
Ich mach jetzt stumpf die Anleitung einfach
Make-Config, bam, und jetzt hier kompilieren starten mit 8 Kern
Hier wird's big brained, massive brained wird hier
Also Leute, wer noch nie gesehen hat, wie ein Linux Kernel kompiliert
Jetzt könnt ihr zugucken, ich sag euch, es ist nicht sonderlich spannend
Und ich hoffe es gibt keine Fehler
Vor und danach Modul installen und dann mal gucken
So Leute, ähm, während das hier so schön kompilt
Hab ich irgendwelche Fragen oder Subs übersehen?
Also wenn ihr Fragen habt, haut's in den Chat, wir haben jetzt 32 Minuten Zeit uns das anzugucken
Alles
Virtuelle Maschine, wie gesagt, Forever Workstation
Ähm
Gerne die M3U testweise schicken, man kann die aber nicht flüstern
Die M3U? Was für eine M3U? Ach du meinst für Fritzbox?
Das bringt mir ja nix, weil es ja nur für dich funktioniert
Also ich seh jetzt im Chat nix mehr
Ah, wie kann ich meinen Terminal auch so aussehen lassen? Das ist eigentlich ziemlich easy
Du nimmst einfach Gnome Terminal, das hab ich
Stellst als Schriftart ein, Pack Regular 15
Und installierst dir das Base 16 ähm, Color, Farbschema
Für Shell und Gnome Terminal, und dann sieht das genauso aus wie bei mir
Ich finde am wichtigsten ist die Schriftart, ich hab's jetzt heute im Chat schon ein bisschen gelesen
Es hat jeder so ein bisschen eigene Präferenz, mir persönlich gefällt Hack am besten als Schriftart
Ich hab jetzt übrigens gelesen, Microsoft hat einen neuen Fond, einen neuen Programmierfond
Die könnten wir uns jetzt grad mal angucken, hab ich letztens gelesen, die haben einen neuen Fond
Cascadia Code, wollen wir uns den mal angucken? PC Lust, ich frag wie geht's dir?
Mir würd's viel besser gehen, wenn der Kernelscheid kompiliert wäre
Entwicklst du das Gehäuse für den Odroid selber? Ähm, nee, ich werd mal hier auf Stingiverse gucken, was es für einen 3D Drucker gibt
Schauen wir mal, was gibt's denn für Gehäuse?
So, hier
Ok, das ist nicht schön gedruckt, aber so was da ist doch schon mal ganz gut
Äh, nee, das ist was anderes
Ich glaube, wenn ich das ordentlich ausdrücke mit meinem Drucker, dann sieht das auch schöner aus
Ok, dann können wir nachher mal gucken
Du könntest mir das per E-Mail schicken, das wär am besten
Guck mal auf meinem YouTube-Channel, da hab ich unter der Kontakt, unter About, gibt's meine Business-E-Mail-Adresse
Wenn du es da hinschicken könntest, wär richtig nice, dann probier ich das nämlich aus
Aber nicht on stream, weil du willst ja nicht, dass man deine Streams gucken kann
Das wär wirklich richtig nice, dann probier ich's aus und sag dir Bescheid, ob das funktioniert
Glaubst du, dass Pyzen immer mehr C++ bzw. die Sharp ersetzt? Nö, das sind andere Anwendungszwecke
Also es wird auf jeden Fall immer verbreiteter werden
Ich mein, Pyzen siehst du mittlerweile, es ist sau viel im Forschungsbereich, also Science-Geschichten
Auch alle möglichen Hexor-Sachen sind mittlerweile in Pyzen, wenn sie keine Low-Level-Sachen erfordern
Das ist ziemlich viel, ja
Könntest du mal deine Heimautomatisierung reden? Gerne auch ein Video drüber
Ja, könnte ich machen, also erzählt hab ich ja im Stream schon echt viel Video, muss ich mal gucken
Dazu muss ich erstmal mein Heimautomatisierung-Server wieder installieren, weil hat's ja wie gesagt gestern zerrissen
Weil ich die USB draufgeschmissen habe
DaFobi, Twitch Prime, 2 Monate, Dankeschön, Poggers
Ja, ich könnte meine E3-Config auf GitHub stellen, allerdings hab ich da so viele Dinger drin stehen
Teilweise auch Aliasse und Kram, alles, wo ich erstmal ewig aufräumen müsste
Was ist aus dem lieben Kram Boom geworden? Ich würd mal vermuten, dem geht's ziemlich gut
Hey Max, ich hab dich vor 1-2 Wochen auf dem Discord-Server gefragt, ob du ein Black Ops 1 Gameplay möchtest
Das ich letztens noch gefunden habe, 75-15 Domination Nuketown
Erstmal nicht, ich hab selbst noch jede Menge Black Ops 1 Gameplay
Hast du Hardware-Empfehlungen für einen sparsamen Home-Server für Game-Server und Storage-Zeugs?
Kommt drauf an, was du da drauf laufen lassen willst, Performance-mäßig
Ansonsten kann ich dir nur die ganzen Jiminy-Lake-Boards empfehlen
Die sind wirklich saumäßig sparsam, wenn du alles eingeschaltet hast, 6 Watt Eidl
Aber das Ding hat zwar einen Quad-Core, allerdings ist es halt nicht sonderlich schnell
Je nachdem, was du für Performance brauchst
So, ok, wo gibt's denn die Schrift von Microsoft zum Downloaden?
Oder mal gucken, vielleicht ist das ja schon in den User-Repost drinnen
Hey, da ist es doch
Was, out of date?
Wo gibt's das denn zum Downloaden?
Ja, und wo gibt's das zu Downloaden?
Ja, draufgeschmissen ist wörtlich gemeint, Ghost Rider
Äh, Dönerbruder, oh das ist eine interessante Frage, sagt
In deinem letzten Video hast du gesagt, dass die Sharp eine gute Programmiersprache ist
Ähm, dass die Sharp eine gute Programmiersprache ist
Und dein, mein Prof meinte heute, dass die Sharp zu abhängig von Windows ist
Was sagst du dazu, dass er keine Ahnung von der aktuellen Entwicklung hat?
Das hat mit Windows überhaupt gar nichts zu tun
Wir haben eine komplette Web-Anwendung schon im Stream unter Linux, für Linux entwickelt
Mit.NET Core und C Sharp
Ja, ich hab's bekommen, Dankeschön
Macht der Kabu noch was aktiv? Keine Ahnung
Ja, wo gibt's denn diese komische neue Microsoft Schrift da zum Download?
Wie heißt das Ding? Cascadia Code
Download
Steht auf GitHub, jawoll
19.10.04
Wobei wir können das untere einfach installieren
Und dann gucken wir mal wie das ganze ausschaut, bin ja mal gespannt, also, so es installiert
Cass, Cass, ach muss ich, haben wir im T-Max gestartet, ok
Gucken wir mal wie das aussieht
Ok, ja
Irgendwie ist die Schriftart nicht da
Ja gut, mal gucken ob sie in Visual Studio Code da ist
Wie kann man den Font hier noch mal einstellen, so, ne
Alter, ok, fort
Warum findet die Schriftart ja nicht
Gucken wir mal ob Rider das ganze findet
Wie funktionieren eigentlich Containerordnungen, das kann ich jetzt so, das kann ich jetzt nicht
Mal nebenbei aus dem Ärmel schütteln
Prinzip basieren Container darauf, dass du verschiedene Mechanismen im Kernel hast um Prozesse gegeneinander abzugrenzen
Und den Prozessen teilweise vorzugaukeln, dass es halt manche Sachen nicht gebe
Also Container ist halt, ist keine Isolierung wie es nur vor allem ist oder so
Weil wir hier die Schriftart haben
Dafür ist im Prinzip ein Container sehr leichtgewichtig, weil es im Prinzip einfach nur ein bisschen Isolierung um Prozesse sind
Du hast, oder Namespaces nennt es sich ja da
Du hast zum Beispiel ein Namespace für das Custom Font
Ok, haben wir das hier drinne vielleicht
Hier ist das Ding Cascadia Code, da ist es doch, save
Ok, das ist jetzt Cascadia Code
Ok, Leute, Cascadia Code am Start
Neuer Font von Microsoft, sieht eigentlich ganz schick aus oder
Ach Moment
Das ist für das UI
Lull, Moment
Wo ändert man den Font hier
Cascadia Code
Save
Jetzt haben wir Cascadia Code
E
Das ist ja eklig
Was für eine Lieblings- und Oberfläche verwendest du in einer Form, das ist Manjaro mit i3-WM
Ich probiere das nach dem Stream aus mit Cody
Oder? Wir können es jetzt auch, wir können es auch mal jetzt onstream probieren
Cody, was für einen Addon braucht man? Simple IPTV
Simple, Simple IPTV
Klingt nach Scamas, Addon
Ja, aber wie ist das denn?
Ich kann es dir nicht, dein Name ist echt schwer für mich
Lucius, wahrscheinlich Lucius, Lucius
Kann man denn damit dann auch in Cody aufnehmen und Serienaufnahmen und sowas machen?
Comic Sans der Rivate, sieht fast so aus
Ah, das können wir onstream testen, ok
Also das heißt wir brauchen Simple IPTV Addon für Cody
Nur denn, GIF
Was macht eigentlich mein Kompiliervorgang? Ok, er kompiliert noch vor sich hin
Wir kompilieren an allen Fronten, so wie es aussieht
Ryder ist ein Java-Programm, womit man C Sharp entwickeln kann
Allerdings, dieses ganze Chat-Brain-Troix ist halt alles auf Java-Basis
Ok, starten wir Cody mal
Wie kann man Cody eigentlich im Fenstermodus starten?
Geht das irgendwie? Kann man dem irgendwie sagen Fenster-Fenster-Modus oder so?
Hä? Bin ich jetzt zu dumm? Wo kann man, wo, wo
kann man den Kram dann hier installieren?
Hä?
My Addons, P4R Clients, da ist es doch
Ja, da muss ich, da muss ich die Datei von dir rüber kopieren
Nee, das ist, ehrlich gesagt, das ist mir jetzt onstream nichts
Ich will da nichts aus Versehen von dir irgendwie leaken oder so
Wer weiß, was das Ding anzeigt
Das probier ich mal lieber, das probier ich da am Stream, dann sag ich dir gleich Bescheid
Oh, der kompiliert immer noch, vielleicht machen wir das jetzt doch
Ok, ähm, gut, dann kopier ich das jetzt, aber
Mach dich bereit zum Router neu starten, falls ich irgendwas liege, ne?
Dann kann ich es selbst ja klar machen
Ok, Downloads, ich speicher mir den Kram jetzt gerade mal auf dem anderen Rechner
Und hat es jetzt rüber kopiert
Ok
Ok, und jetzt kopieren wir den Kram mal in
In die VM
Alter, was, was, rum, rum, tracken, droppen, Alter
Erstmal wieder ausmachen, ja
Was?
Was hat der denn für Schmerzen jetzt gerade beim Kopieren in die VM
Hat er das jetzt gemacht?
Hat er das jetzt kopiert oder nicht?
Jetzt hat er es kopiert
Ok
M3U
Jetzt probieren wir das mit Cody mal aus, und bis wir das ausprobiert haben, würde ich sagen
Dann sollte wahrscheinlich auch das kernel kompilieren fertig sein
Simple IPTV, Configure
Ich gucke jetzt mal auf der anderen Seite in die Datei rein
Das ist doch kein Domain von dir
Das ist irgendeine
Filesharing, sonst was Domain, die da drinnen steht, oder?
AVM, ja, ich kann das, ich mache es im Stream an, allerdings ohne Bild
Ich mache es zumindest mal testweise ohne Bild, aber wer weiß nicht, dass da irgendwelche Porn am Start ist oder so
Local Paths, so Home-Folder
Ok, Enable
Exit
Jetzt starten wir mal neu und gucken, ob das funktioniert
Cody, ich weiß, wie ich es mache
Nach TV
Ok, wir gucken jetzt, ob es funktioniert
Wir machen das BibelTV, wo ist BibelTV? Ich brauche BibelTV
Hast du nicht BibelTV gemapped?
Ok, dann gucken wir jetzt Euro News
N24Doku
Tagesschau, Tagesschau 24
Ok, ich muss irgendwie mal gucken, dass ich das hinkriege
Neugierdnis
Ja gut, dann weiß ich auch nicht
Jetzt erst mal wieder Disable
Aber wenn das funktionieren würde, wäre echt cool
Exit
So, schauen wir mal, ob es fertig kompiliert ist
Nein, nicht fertig kompiliert, Leute, wir haben noch ein bisschen Zeit, wir können noch ein bisschen Zeug ausprobieren
Ja, mach das mal, kannst ruhig gucken
Hast genug Zeit
Kann man Simple IPTV Recording, geht das?
Kann Simple IPTV Recorden
War ganz davon abgesehen, wozu sollte ich das alles in Kodi machen
Genau dafür ist TV Head-and-Dar
Ich muss jetzt noch mal eine ZSH-Settings sein, ne, da sind wahrscheinlich zu viele, da sind wahrscheinlich noch Aliase drin
Weil ich habe die Kram von meiner Arbeits-VM, also von dem, was ich immer zum Arbeiten verwende, kopiert
Und ich weiß nicht, ob da nicht irgendein Kram drin ist, den ich nicht zeigen kann und nicht zeigen sollte
Okay, wir sind bei Driver-USP-Storage, das heißt, wir sind relativ weit, oder?
Ja, wir sind fast fertig mit dem Kernel-Build
Fehlt nicht mal viel, Kernel-Build ist fast durch
So, was müssen wir jetzt als nächstes machen?
Oh ne, wir sind doch noch nicht fertig
Die haben uns richtig gebadet wieder, schon das vierte Mal gebadet an dem Tag
Also Leute, ihr seht, Kernel-Kompilieren hört sich aufregender an als es ist, es ist stinkelangweilig
Wie hast du deine M auf Papierkorb gemapped?
Gar nicht, das ist ein Programm, was sich, ich glaube, Thresh-CLI oder so nennt
Das da, das macht das für dich
Das ist wahrscheinlich unter der Haube, nur auch irgendwie ein 15-Zeilen-Bash-Script oder so
Aber das ist halt sehr praktisch, weil da kannst du halt irgendwas löschen hier, keine Ahnung
Löschst du halt den Kram hier und dann sagst du Thresh-List
Und da hast du den ganzen Kram wieder
Und dann sagst du Thresh-Empty und das ist alles weg
Das ist wirklich ganz praktisch
Das ist eines der wenigen Sachen unter Windows, die ich für eine gute Idee halte
Dieses System mit Papierkorb
Oh, jetzt ist er wirklich fast fertig
Kernel fertig kompiliert, easy
Okay, als nächstes Make Modules
Die Musik ist übelst leise, kann das sein?
Ah, schon besser
Okay, wie geht's weiter? Das da, wir zp'n irgendwelche Dinger
Okay, wir zp'n noch mehr Dinger, auch gut
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was wir da machen
Wir kopieren irgendwelche Boot-Config, auch gut
Wir machen eine neue Initram FS zum Booten, auch gut
Machen wir alles, easy
Danach machen wir ein neues Image
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was der da macht, aber
Also alles, was er jetzt macht, ist klar
Generiert neues Image zum Starten, bzw. neue ID zum Starten
Zum Booten, zack, aber was da so im Detail passiert, keine Ahnung
Wir führen einfach die Anleitung jetzt aus
Zack, Boot, jo
Sync, Reboot, okay
Also, wenn das jetzt alles funktioniert, dann sollte das System Rebooten
Und mit einem Kernel 503 wieder hochkommen
Okay, YOLO
Ping
Der blinkt irgendwie so komisch
Okay, das Netzwerke-Interface ist gerade wieder angegangen
Aber ich glaube, das geht schlicht und ergreifend immer wieder an
Ch-ch-chibated, ch-ch-ch-chibated
Das dauert viel zu lang mit dem Reboot
First booting might stop
Okay
Wait 2 minutes and do a cold boot
Haben wir schon 2 minutes gewartet?
Schon 2 minutes her?
Egal, ich mache jetzt Strom aus und Strom an und gucke, ob es funktioniert
Strom ist wieder drin
Hoffentlich geht der Kram jetzt
Ich brauche 5er Kernel brauche ich
Das ist kein Display, nein, das Ding hat auch gar keine Displayausgabe
Oh Leute, ich glaube, das Ding ist RIP
Lulve, haben wir irgendwas von den Schritten hier vergessen?
Ich habe alles gemacht, oder?
Wobei hätte ich das nicht gemacht, hätte das nicht funktioniert
Ja ja, doch
Ich gucke mal in meinem Router, ob da sich vielleicht eine andere IP genommen hat
Aber ich glaube ja nicht
Wir warten jetzt einfach nochmal kurz und dann starte ich nochmal neu
Okay
TCP Server, Leases
Nee
Hat sich keine andere Lease geholt
Okay, Leute, ich ziehe nochmal den Strom raus
So, ich lasse jetzt mal den Strom ein bisschen draußen kurz, mal gucken
Gucken, was passiert, ich lasse mal meinen Router auf und schaue, ob da sich irgendwie meldet
Scheiße ey, fuck, warum ist das Ding jetzt im Arsch, wir haben doch alles richtig gemacht ey
Willst du mal schon auf BDO, nee
Okay Leute, also, wir lassen den jetzt mal bis 50 stehen und dann reboot ich nochmal und gucke, ob es dann funktioniert
Ob es ein fertiges Image gibt, ich habe keins gefunden
Wir könnten Armbian installieren, ja, aber es ist auch schon ganz schön spät, ich habe jetzt eigentlich darauf gehofft, dass das funktioniert
Ja, ich meine, das muss nicht funktionieren, das ist halt eine Anleitung aus dem offiziellen Forum, aber sowas kann immer mal in die Hose gehen
Das haben wir gemacht, das haben wir gemacht, da bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob ich das auch gemacht habe
Aber doch, doch, das habe ich auch ausgeführt
Würdest du die VPN-Funktion der Fritzbox verwenden, um beispielsweise eine OnCloud-Installation im Netzwerk zu erreichen, ja, warum nicht
Okay, jetzt bis 50 warten wir jetzt
Bis 50 warten wir jetzt, dann starte ich nochmal neu und gucke, ob es dann funktioniert
Also dann dansen.
Also ne, ich muss jetzt nochmal den
Ich muss eigentlich nochmal avenues
Das ist eigentlich eine super geschichte ja war als sprache finde ich halt unglaublich
Wie soll ich sagen wie doppelt gemoppelt ja
Das einzige was wirklich bei ja war halt lange zeit genervt hat es die startzeiten
Aber ansonsten gibt eigentlich
Eigentlich ist nicht so ist es nicht so das ja war als unbenutzbar scheiße wäre oder so
Ok leute jetzt haben aber zwei minuten gewartet oder
Jetzt haben wir doch echt zwei minuten gewartet
Ok also jetzt mache ich noch mal strom raus noch mal strom rein ich schalte jetzt direkt an der steckdose aus und ein
Ok schauen wir mal
Scheiße
Das ding hat auch kein display adapter dass ich gucken können was er macht
Ich würde sagen das ding ist ripp also ich meine gut wir können jetzt eine neue sd-karte machen aber habe ich jetzt kein bock drauf
Fuck
Das nervt mich jetzt nervt mich echt richtig
Meinung zu skala kann ich gar nicht
Ok wir machen jetzt noch mal trick 17. Wir machen jetzt den guten alten nintendo trick
Kennt ihr den guten alten nintendo trick
SD karte pusten
Nicht dass es was bringen wird aber man weiß ja nie
Und auf den netzwerkanschluss so und jetzt mit schmackes den stecker rein
Und
Ihr mich verarschen was du teufel ist das
Das
Was was
Hä
Warte fack das check ich nicht dass das das das
Also leute es gibt ja es gab ja in der vergangenheit
Es gab ja in der vergangenheit schon so so computer mäßig viele sachen die ich nicht verstanden habe ja
Aber das ist echt eines der verwirrendsten sachen die ich je erlebt habe
Ist echt eines der verwirrendsten sachen die ich je erlebt habe
Ach so er hier atmen
Und atmen 12 3 4 5 6
Hallo
5 6
Hallo atmen 1 2 3 4 5 6 geht doch
Habe ich ja nicht meine key inkopiert
Und
und jetzt jetzt kommt der moment der wahrheit leute der moment der wahrheit
ich habe den adapter rausgezogen deswegen erkennt er den adapter nicht
ok adapter eingesteckt beide tuner da leute beide tuner da easy as fuck
sehr gut sehr gut sehr gut
ok dann würde ich sagen richten wir jetzt mal unity media ein hc res switch prime
dankeschön für den sub sub prime sub
subscriber
ok also so tv hat ein konfigurieren man sagt networks at das habe ich ja mittlerweile so
oft gemacht dass ich auswendig weiß wie diese beschissene benutzerführung geht leute wenn ihr
denkt ihr wisst wie man wie man den sender suchlauf macht ihr habt es noch nie gesehen
wie man das in tv hat er macht ist das komplizierteste was irgendwie geht
sagt ihr erst mal new dvb 10 network dann sagt man hier sowas wie unity media dann kann man
predefined muxes auswählen da nimmt man hessen den rest ignoriert man den braucht man gar nicht sagt
create dann macht man dann geht man in die adapters enable den adapter fügt unity media bei dem
jeweiligen adapter hinzu save save enable save dann geht man auf networks macht skip start up
scan weg und jetzt sollte er eigentlich scannen übelst kompliziert oder jetzt sollte er eigentlich
scannen und wenn er jetzt nicht scannt dann muss man noch mal sagen vor scan unglaublich kompliziert
oder ok jetzt scanter fail da sollte eigentlich nicht fail stehen da sollte not found oder sowas
stehen fail ist schlecht ja ja ich habe kein kabel dran ich habe kein kabel dran aber fail
sollte da eigentlich nicht stehen ich glaube ich glaube da steht normalerweise not found oder
irgendwie sowas wenn es funktioniert ich habe ein odroid hc 2 gerade dieses dieses nass für arme
mach mal dvbc signal dran ja mache ich ich lasse ihn jetzt erst einmal kurz durchlaufen ich hoffe
wenn ich ihn jetzt neu starte dass ich die nicht wieder fünf mal neu starten muss besser funktioniert
und für für braucht man fernsehen ja ich brauche gar nicht meine mutter braucht das ich nicht
ich muss ihn aber neu starten weil ich muss ihn jetzt gleich ins wohnzimmer bringen und im
wohnzimmer das kabel dran dran stöpseln womit greifst du dann später auf die streams so kodi
kodi mit dem passenden tv head und plugin dauert aber nicht mal lang bis wir sehen ob es funktioniert
ok also das funktioniert so schon mal nicht na gut leute auf auf und ich bringe das ding mal ins
wohnzimmer rüber und schauen wir mal man ks ich bin gleich wieder da
so
das dauert schon zu lang muss ich den kram jetzt echt zehn mal neu starten bis funktioniert
oder was was da los dauert schon wieder zu lang ich gehe jetzt noch mal rüber pusten klein
puster 82 machen wir jetzt kenne den überhaupt noch jemand puster 82 was nutzt du für eine
karte stick ich benutze irgendeine samsung 32 g evo plus ja nichts gekostet die hatten
wir amazon aus versehen mitgeschickt ok leute das funktioniert nicht ich lasse den ping mal
laufen ich gehe jetzt noch mal rüber hatte nicht angefangen medizinstudien nee das war
kyla junge kyla junge 94 oder so ist der glaube ich ist das kabel im wohnzimmer im selben
netzwerk wie in einem set up ja ja das ist alles internes netz ja ich gehe noch mal kurz rüber
und zieht das rein raus wie ok wir wissen einfach man muss nur oft genug starten dann
funktioniert es habe eben gesehen
ob es jetzt geht klapper klapper ich glaube ich habe es gecheckt woran das
liegt man muss das ding einfach ein bisschen länger auslassen man kann man darf das ding
nicht ausschalten wieder einschalten man muss man muss es ausschalten irgendwie langsam
bis zehn zählen wieder einschalten dann funktioniert komisches teil wir wir kopieren übrigens
mal und den ssk ssh hier hin dass wir nicht immer in den mist eintippen müssen ok also
das gännen wir noch mal würde ich sagen es gännen wir doch noch mal forst gänn gucken
ich will nur subscriber lesen nicht unsubscribing aus dem unsubscribing nicht sondern disabbot
ich habe den stecker am otroid gezogen failed das kennt nicht der das kennt aber der kackt
ab der findet nix schauen wir mal unseren freund den karnel lock
da
Das, oh mann
Ey wenn es das jetzt ist, beiß ich mir in Arsch, äh
Das braucht noch irgendeine Herstellerfirma, das Ding, dass es funktioniert
Das Ding braucht noch irgendeine Herstellerfirma, dass es funktioniert
Das Ding braucht noch irgendeine Herstellerfirma, das Ding, dass es funktioniert
Welche Hardware benutzt du gerade? Das ist ein Odroid HC2 mit einem WinTV Dual HD USB Stick
Das Ding braucht noch irgendeine Herstellerfirma, dass es funktioniert
Colonel kompiliert, Firmware vergessen, Reboot, Neustartprobleme, alles dabei, was das Herz eines Linux-Fans höher schlagen lässt
Ok mal gucken bis er fertig scannt ist
Aber ihr seht schon, wir haben hier die ersten Sender am Start
Beziehungsweise die ersten, wie nennt sich das denn? Das sind keine Sender
Oder? Das sind Dings hier, so, so, so, so
Frequenzen
Ok, ok, ok, none steht da, wenn er nichts findet, genau, nicht fail
Active, der ist noch am scannen
Ja, aber du hast doch irgendwie, du hast doch bei DVBC, hast du doch irgendwie auf so einer Sendergruppe, hast du doch mehrere Sender
Das ist, das ist so ne Gruppe, also du hast hier quasi sowas wie, du müsstest hier ne Gruppe haben für beispielsweise ARD oder so
Und das wär dann, da wär dann alles drinne, so Dreisart, ARD und, ach keine Ahnung
Wobei nee, das sind tatsächlich alles Sender, sonst hätten wir nicht 575 Sender
Ist denn da auch Bibel-TV dabei?
Der wichtigste Sender für mich Leute, ich brauch Bibel-TV, wo ist Bibel-TV?
Unter B, Bibel-TV
Aber wo ist Bibel, ich, ey ich kann nicht ohne Bibel-TV, geht nicht
Ah feels bad, da war's, echt, wo?
Wo?
Wo? Ah!
Ja Gott sei Dank, endlich Bibel-TV, äh
Zum Glück, jetzt, jetzt kann ja nichts, kann ja nichts mehr schief gehen, ja
Sogar HD
Endlich mal, dass ich das Emote verwenden kann
Ok, ist er fertig mit scannen?
Ok, der macht jetzt EPG-Crap oder so
Ok, der, der ist fertig, scannen
So, an als nächstes geht man auf Services, nach Map, Map All Service
Äh, keine verschlüsselten
Und nach Map
Kann es sein, dass Kabel-Deutsche RTSP blockiert? Kann ich mir gut vorstellen, meine Jungs, ja
Ok
Alles gemapped, jetzt können wir mal unser Kodi starten
TV
Add-on-Browser
RTSP
Ok
Add-on-Browser
Naja, my add-ons
Gvr-Klines
Alter, was
Geht was mit der Maus los, äh
Was ist das hier, hier?
Ähm
Und mit dem Setup kann man jetzt im ganzen Netzwerk auf allen Geräten Fernsehen, ja, ja
Wenn es funktioniert, sehen wir jetzt gleich
Configure, IP-Adress, also
2.123, Bam
Username, TV, Haar, Passwort
Hallo, Passwort, 123456
Wir sehen schon gleich, ob es funktioniert, wenn man die Senderlisten lädt
Enable
Lädt
Ah, hat die Sender schon geladen
Ok, Guide, Radio-Channels
Ja, wo ist Bibel-TV?
Wo?
Leute
Wo ist es?
Da!
HD
Wäre ich jetzt gebannt, wenn ich das anmach?
Da ist es!
Ok, evangelische Glauben am Start
Funktioniert, wow
Blackscreen
Porgers
Funktioniert
Fernsehfunst
Ich meine, jetzt müsste man noch Senderlogo installieren und sowas
Was hat der Spaß jetzt gekostet?
Na, der Stick
Der DVPT-Stick
Du brauchst einen DVPT-Stick
Für Dual-Tuner-Stick für 60 Euro
Du brauchst den Odroid für 60 Euro
Was?
Mikro SD-Karte hat man eigentlich
Und wenn du aufnehmen willst, brauchst du noch eine Festplatte für das Ding
Aber da reicht eine billige 2TB oder so
Ist in Dual-Tuner-Stick Pflicht
Kommt auf dich
Ich finde schon, dass du aufnehmen und gleichzeitig gucken kannst
Nice
Glaube im Osten
Der Osten meldet sich zurück
Man kann auch gucken und aufnehmen gleichzeitig, solange es die gleiche Sendergruppe ist
Das ist korrekt
Aber meistens ist es nicht die gleiche Sendergruppe, die du gucken und aufnehmen willst
Ja, das sieht schon so aus
Das heißt, jetzt muss ich nur noch über Nacht die ganzen Aufnahmen vom alten rüber kopieren aufs Neue
Achso, noch eine Festplatte muss ich noch dran machen
Eine Festplatte muss ich noch dran machen
Was gibt es eigentlich für coole Kodi...
Aber wie macht man diesen komischen Soundtrack? Da kriege ich ja Anfälle bei
Interface
Wo macht man die Sounds back?
Sounds wegmachen
Sounds nerven mich
System
Audio
Na ja
Play GUI Sounds
Geh weg
Geh weg, never
Was gibt es denn eigentlich für coole Skins für Kodi, die noch gepflegt werden?
Hat da jemand eine schöne Skin Empfehlung?
Weil ich muss sagen, der default Skin ist jetzt nicht der allerschönste, ne?
Matrix-mäßig ist der ne, ich will irgendwas angenehmes haben
Ace
Aura
Aura, klingt doch gut
Kodi Aura-Skin, wie sieht denn das Ding aus?
Doch, Bilder
Bilder
Confluence
Confluence, das erinnert mich so an dieses Atlassian-Ding
Amber-Skin
Oh ne, das ist nicht so meins
Aber Aura sieht eigentlich ganz cool aus
Gucken wir mal
Insta
Oh, Alter
Was will der dann alles installieren noch für diesen komischen Skin?
Ohjejei
Skriptzeug, ahja, mach
Ich kann jetzt kein Kodi einfach wieder löschen, dann ist alles weg
Switch to this skin, yes
Yes
Och, das sieht doch eigentlich ganz schick aus
Gefällt mir gut
Guide
Achja
Gefällt mir jetzt persönlich besser als der Standard-Skin
Alter Tatort in 2019
Warum gibt es heute eigentlich Tatort? Ich dachte Tatort gibt es immer Sonntagabend
Gibt es Sonntagabend auch wieder Tatort?
Moment, 8 PM muss ich gucken
Tatort, noch mehr Tatort, Alter was mit denen los? Das wird ja im Akkord
Ich wollte gerade sagen im Akkord programmiert, im Akkord verfilmt
Was ist da Netflix für einen Sender? Moment, ich hab da echt Netflix drinne stehen?
Also wahrscheinlich ist das irgendein Werbeding, ich hab ja auch Unity-Media-Sender drinstehen
Gab es echt einen Sender der Netflix heißt?
Ganz unten, ok ok ganz unten
Netflix
Macht es mal, ok
Kann man sich Netflix irgendwie über Unity-Media streamen lassen für alle die zu noobig sind das übers Internet zu machen?
Streamen die das irgendwie custom zu mir wenn ich Netflix hab?
Das ist bestimmt doch, das ist bestimmt so ein Unity-Media-Service den man auf der Horizon Box machen kann
Du kannst bestimmt auf der Horizon Box Netflix ansteuern und Netflix geht dann nicht übers Internet sondern über Kabel zu dir oder so
Die machen da bestimmt ganz abgedrehtes Zeug ich will es gar nicht wissen
Ich würde sagen wir nehmen das jetzt mal auf oder?
Das ist wirklich ein High Quality Programm, aber das ist ein guter Test Sender, das ist ein guter Test Sender wenn man mal gucken will ob es funktioniert
Ja also ich muss sagen das Deinterlacing ist ganz wichtig bei diesem Programm
Taugt eigentlich, taugt eigentlich das YouTube Addon mittlerweile was?
Mausbedienung ist übelst fail, Video Addons sind das ne? Taugt das Kodi YouTube Addon mittlerweile was? Das letzte Mal war einfach übelst räudig schlecht
Settings, Addon, ok Moment, Addon Repo, Repo, fuck Alter Moment die Bedienung ist wir, Alter Kodi, komm an brah
Ok Install vom Repo, Video Addons, YouTube, ok mal gucken wie das mittlerweile ist
Dependency ist erstmal 50.000 Dinger, ja ja mach
Language and region, yes, select language, ok German, select region, German
Ne man nicht das ich unbedingt so scharf auf YouTube Deutschland bin, ja ach ne jetzt muss ich Deutschland machen
Used for my location, no, die schauen doch per Kabel, deswegen mach ich den Mist doch hier
Und wo seh, wo ist das Addon jetzt, ja YouTube, ihh, ihh ist das schlecht, ok search, news, oh ist das eklig
Popular right now, mal gucken was angesagt ist auf YouTube Deutschland, Monte ein Millionär, ungereagiert, Fußball, Justin reagiert
Laura ist Camgirl, Fanboy, wer zum Teufel ist Simon Will, YouTube Deutschland ist echt traurig
Ok dann suchen wir jetzt mal nach ordentlichem Content ob der das abspielen kann, gucken ob der guten YouTube Content abspielen kann
Channels, oh da ist er, oh ich seh grad mein Hintergrund ist nicht transparent vom Keks
Technik Hacks und China Kram, gucken wir mal ob er mein Video anzeigen kann
Hallo Jungs und Mädels hier ist der Max, bevor das Video losgeht und zwar muss ich euch nämlich was fragen
Ich hab mich hingesetzt und hab mal so die letzten, äh wie kann ich lauter und leiser machen
Das Video geht unter 20 Minuten lang und mich würde jetzt einfach mal interessieren ob euch das Ganze gefällt, das heißt wenn euch das Video gefällt dann erstens natürlich den Subbutton und zweitens sagt mir nochmal in den Kommentaren Bescheid ob euch das Ganze gefällt, ob ihr da mehr von sehen wollt, weil wie gesagt ich hab Berge an irgendwelchem Technik Kram nicht nur China Kram alles mögliche und mich würd's einfach wirklich mal interessieren ob ihr mehr von der Sache sehen wollt
So, übrigens das ist noch ein guter Grund für Android TV, in Android TV hast du einfach die offizie, wow das Ding ist aber ganz schön schnell im Scrollen
Auf Android TV hast du einfach die offizielle YouTube App, die ist zwar auch kacke, aber besser als dieses Ding da, das ist ja abartig, wer soll das verwenden
Wer soll dieses Addon verwenden, ich mein es ist okay für wenn man sonst nix hat ja, aber wirklich schön zu bedienen ist es halt nicht
Einfach Cody auf Fire TV, ja zum Beispiel, na Fire TV ist ja auch ein Android TV, na ja mit Amazon Android TV
Aha, Power, das sieht nicht so gut aus
Ich würd sagen wir gucken uns nochmal hier das Qualitätsprogramm an
Fire TV hat die YouTube App nicht, die kann man sich doch garantiert sideloaden oder, ich hab auch einen ordentlichen Browser sideloaded
Aber der Skin gefällt mir, der Skin ist hübsch
Wow, das hab ich kaputt gemacht, bewegt sich nicht mehr, ach jetzt doch, man kann sogar, die Areale
Oh man kann sogar richtig viel einstellen, Fan Art das geht mir immer auf den Keks, das mach ich immer aus
Aber die default Settings sind doch auch ganz gut
Also der Skin hat was, würd ich sagen, find ich echt ganz, ganz nice
Library, wir haben keine Music Library, gibt es eigentlich mittlerweile ein ordentliches Addon für Amazon?
Gibt es ein ordentliches Amazon Addon? Wahrscheinlich nicht, oder?
Also eins das funktioniert
Gucken wir mal
Ja
Hier guck mal mal, Video Addons, ach Quatsch, Moment das sind nicht meine
Install von Video Addons, Amazon, welches ist das richtig jetzt hier?
Ich seh überhaupt kein Amazon, oder heißt das Prime? Das heißt wahrscheinlich Prime
Du musst das Coding als Repo hinzufügen, ah ok daher weht der Wind
Prime
Ok wirklich offiziell ist das nicht, dann
Gronkh hier anscheinend hat Gronkh ein eigenes Coding Addon, keine Ahnung
Ja, jetzt guck ich mir aber mal die Tage an, also
Das brauch ich ja glücklicherweise auf Android TV nicht, weil ich auf Android TV die offizielle Amazon App hab
Leute ich bin echt begeistert easy, wollen wir jetzt noch mal Rebooten und gucken ob das jetzt den Reboot überlebt
Versuchst du für ein Gerät ein Odroid HC2 mit USB Dual Tuner
Nee ich kann nicht alle Sender empfangen
Wo soll ich denn, mit was soll ich denn die Sender empfangen? Ich hab nen Shield TV als Frontend
Und ich weiß nicht wie gut mittlerweile auf dem Shield TV die Tuner Unterstützung ist
Keine Ahnung wie gut das auf dem Shield TV direkt funktionieren würde, ich brauch auf jeden Fall nen Tuner
So und was ist jetzt der Vorteil von einem Fernsehserver? Naja ich kann Fernseh gucken und ich kann aufnehmen
Und ich kann im ganzen Haus die Aufnahmen und den Fernseh gucken
Ich kann vor allem Fernseh gucken, was ich jetzt sonst nicht könnte
Außer ich würde die Horizon Box anschließen und dann könnte ich es nur auf einem Gerät gucken
Und würde die Aufnahmen nie von der Festplatte runter kriegen, weil die verschlüsselt sind
Kannst du auch TV auf deiner smarten Toilette gucken? Ja ich könnte auf dem Tablet einfach mich verbinden zu meinem TV Headend und Fernseh gucken
Ich mein es gibt ja Kodi auch fürs Tablet und für Apple gibt es, ich glaub für Apple gibt es kein Kodi, aber es gibt nen TV Headend
Ach gibt's doch, gibt's mittlerweile ein ordentliches Kodi für IOS? Okay
Äh nein, was auch immer das ist, aber es gibt nen TV Headend für IOS, da kann ich beispielsweise, wenn ich möchte mit dem Tablet auf dem Klo Fernseh gucken
Will ich aber nicht, weil ich guck kein Fernseh, ich guck dann lieber Twitch oder YouTube oder sowas
Ich hab's auf dem Shield TV laufen, richtig
Das wichtigste übrigens Leute
Gibt kein ASCII Aquarium, aber dann müssen wir es hier starten
Theoretisch könntest du das Signal ja auch auf den Tuner der im TV integriert ist nutzen, da weiß ich nicht wie ich das rauskriege
Ach so meinst du das, ja aber ich bin mir nicht sicher ob der Fernseh, also erstens keine Ahnung ob der Fernseh einen Dual Tuner hat
Äh und außerdem kann man da keine Platte richtig ansteckt
Das ist so schon viel besser
Zumal es auch nicht teuer ist und ich denke mal, dass es relativ zuverlässig laufen wird
Wieso hast du TV nicht ganz normal über Kabel am TV?
Naja, damit ich die Vorteile hab, die ich gerade aufgezählt hab
Zum Beispiel, dass ich von überall, was heißt von überall, ja theoretisch von überall gucken kann, vor allem auf jedem Endgerät gucken kann
Dass ich Serienaufnahmen machen kann mit ordentlichen Regeln, dass ich Kodi als Frontend verwenden kann, was ordentlich läuft auf dem Shield TV, was auf meinem Sony Fernseh
Also Kodi auf dem Embedded Android TV von den Sony TVs läuft überhaupt nicht gut
Und das Shield TV ist einfach das beste, beste Box, die es gibt, beste Frontend Box
Aber aktuell können nur zwei Geräte gleichzeitig gucken, sofern nicht aufgenommen wird, oder?
Ja und ne, ähm, solange es nicht die gleiche Frequenz ist, oder nicht das gleiche, nicht diese gleiche Sendergruppe
Also wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel keine Ahnung, ZDF gucke und gerade Pro7 oder so aufnehme, dann kann ich ohne Probleme vom Tablet noch zusätzlich Z1 gucken und 3SAT aufnehmen oder so
Oder, also alles was in dieser Sendergruppe liegt
Und ganz ehrlich Leute, sollte das irgendwann mal Probleme machen, mache ich einfach noch einen zweiten Dualtuner dran und gut ist
Welche Hardware verwendest du?
Ich verwende einen, einen hier WinTV Dual HD Stick und einen Odroid HC2
Dieses Ding da, das ist quasi so nass für Arme
Aber für die Sache reicht es, das Ding hat eine 8-Core, eine 8-Core CPU drauf, 4 langsame Cores, 4 schnelle Cores, reicht also für Fernseh ohne Probleme aus
Und da mache ich eine 2TB Uralt WD Green-Platte dran, das reicht auch
Auf meinem Rechter verwende ich Manjaro mit E3WM als Window Manager
Ich gucke ja auch kein Fernseher
Also man hat HD, allerdings nur für öffentlich-rechtliche
Die Privaten brauchen eine Smartcard und Smartcard geht damit nicht
Generell ist dieses ganze Thema, dieses ganze Fernsehthema Verschlüsselung und Smartcard und so ist wirklich ein absolutes Minenfeld
Also da lohnt sich auch das Basteln nicht, ehrlich gesagt
Hast du eine günstige Alternative zum Shield TV? Ja hol dir dann ein Firestick
So, das heißt, wenn ich wirklich private Fernsehsender in HD haben möchte, dann gucke ich entweder in der Mediathek von denen, weil die haben die Sendung in HD, da musst du halt auch Werbung angucken, ok
Oder ich hole mir noch ein Satu-Abo und gucke halt ein HD-Sender, aber ganz ehrlich, ich gucke eh kein Fernseh
Und solange sich meine Mutter nicht beschwert, dass sie kein HD-RTL gucken kann, wird es egal
Und die beschwert sich nicht, dass sie kein HD-RTL gucken kann, ganz einfach aus dem Grund, weil die den Unterschied zwischen SD und HD eh nicht richtig sieht
Das ist halt so die Generation, die sich den Unterschied zwischen HD und HD nicht richtig sieht
Ich mein, für uns ist der Unterschied zwischen einem HD-Sender und einem SD-Sender über 15km zu sehen, übertrieben gesagt, aber es gibt Leute, die sehen den Unterschied nicht
Und die, die, die lügen, die, die, die lügen das nicht, die, die faken das nicht, die, die sehen das wirklich nicht
Sollte das sein
Das ist die Mini-Variante von meinem ohne Sata, so sollte man dann sowas machen
Einfach durchgeschnitten hier
Doch, die sieht gut, aber die erkennen den Unterschied nicht, zumal der Sony Fernseh ganz gutes Upscaling hat, genau, genau
Ne, Moment, der Fernsehsender upscaled das ganze nicht
Achso, du meinst, die Sachen, die in HD ausgeschrieben werden, sind zum größten Teil hochskaliert
Ich weiß nicht, ob das noch so ist, aber selbst wenn, der Sony Fernseh macht auch ganz gutes Upscaling
Das ist der einzige Kritikpunkt, den ich am Shield TV habe, oder man müsste mal schauen, wie es jetzt ist, dass als ich mir das Shield TV gekauft habe, war das 4K Upscaling ziemlich schlecht
Also das Upscaling von 1080p auf 4K war damals beim Shield TV ziemlich kacke
Und auch noch ein negativer Punkt, der ist aber glaube ich mittlerweile halbwegs in Griff, dass unterschiedliche Anwendungen nicht unterschiedliche Auflösungen haben können
Das ist auch ein bisschen doof, weil ich möchte, dass Amazon Prime in 4K läuft und Kodi in 1080p
Warum? Weil ich will, dass bei Kodi der Sony Fernseher das Upscaling macht
Und bei Amazon sind die Filme schon in 4K, da muss nichts mehr ge-Upscaled werden
Schaust du keinen Fernseher? Nö
Ich schaue auch keine Aufnahmen, ich schaue gar nichts
Eine Mutter guckt, ich gucke nicht
Wo kann dann beim Upscaling die Qualität variieren?
Das ist ganz viel Quickmuffs, was Upscaling angeht, das kann ich dir so nicht erklären
Da gibt es zig Verfahren, sowohl für Upscaling als auch für Downscaling
Welche Projekte kommen in Zukunft? Müssen wir uns mal auf uns zukommen lassen, ich kann es dir gerade nicht sagen
Wir müssen noch mal einen Versandtracker fertig programmieren
Aber das kann ich dir nicht erklären, ich weiß nur, dass es zig Varianten sowohl für Upscaling als auch für Downscaling gibt
Dass es ja dann auch noch so Magic-Sachen gibt, die quasi mehrere Bilder vergleichen
Und dann die Informationen von den Filmen ausprobieren und dann auch die Informationen von den Filmen ausprobieren
Die quasi mehrere Bilder vergleichen und dann die Informationen daraus nutzen, um besser abzuscalen
Also das ist schon echt, Upscaling ist Big Brain Technologie
Microsoft würde jetzt sagen, wir haben ein Machine Learning AI Upscaling und deswegen ist der besser als alle anderen
Das wäre so eine typische Microsoft Aussage.
Die sagen ja auch, dass Windows jetzt weniger Bugs hat wegen AI.
Hattet ihr das gelesen?
Microsoft says AI powered Windows Updates have reduced bugs.
Das war in die Ernst, ja?
Reduced crashes, nicht reduced bugs.
Aber ich glaube, ich habe bei Heise auch irgendwas gelesen.
Naja, AI ist nur noch Buzz.
Ja, es ist ein bisschen wie vor ein paar Jahren, wo sie alle mit Cloud um sich geworfen haben.
Jetzt werfen zwischenzeitlich haben sie dann alle mit Containern und Docker und Gedöns um sich geworfen.
Und jetzt machen sie alle Blockchain.
Ich habe in letzter Zeit so viel Werbung gesehen und so viele Webseiten, wo irgendwelche...
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht mal, was es ist.
Wahrscheinlich sind es noch nicht mal Startups.
Wahrscheinlich sind es irgendwelche Unternehmen, die cool erscheinen wollen,
die irgendwas von Blockchain faseln.
Und wenn du dir diese Seite durchliest, du denkst dir permanent nur, was lese ich hier überhaupt?
Du hast so viele Seiten, da steht Blockchain Technology und irgendwie der Weg in die Zukunft, blablabla drauf.
Und du liest die Seite und du weißt eigentlich gar nicht, was du dir da durchliest.
Du verstehst es nicht, du verstehst nicht, um was es geht.
Du verstehst nicht, was der Autor dir eigentlich sagen möchte.
Du weißt nicht, um welche Firma es geht.
Du weißt nicht, um welches Produkt es geht.
Das Einzige, was du weißt, ist, dass Blockchain geil und Zukunft.
Ganz viele hauen noch irgendwas mit Blockchain raus.
Ja oder? Wie gesagt, AI und Machine Learning ist auch aktuell voll angesagt.
Sie haben ja auch gesagt, dass irgendwie im neuen, wie ist das im neuen Flight Simulator von Microsoft,
werden die Bäume, die Bäume prozedural AI generiert oder so.
Wo ich mir so denke, was genau brauche ich, um irgendwelche random Bäume in einem Wald zu generieren?
Krasse AI.
Das kam Minecraft schon seit 20 Jahren, seit 50 Jahren macht das Minecraft schon so.
Seit 1850 ist das im Minecraft schon drin.
Hat sogar Napoleon schon im Minecraft gespielt, Bäume prozedural generieren.
Die sollen jetzt mal nicht so tun, als wäre das irgendwas, irgendwas Neues.
Genau, seit Jesus macht das Minecraft schon.
Pfeiffer. Pfeiffer Video mach ich glaube ich am Wochenende.
Ja, wird echt mal Zeit.
Die AI generiert die Häuser von den 2D-Satellitenbilder in 3D.
Ok, das wäre natürlich eine sinnvolle Variante.
Ich hoffe, die AI macht das aber im Vorfeld und nicht bei mir auf dem Rechner, oder?
Das könnte die AI einmal bei der Entwicklung machen und dann ist gut.
Ja, was ist das?
Ja, bei einem Flugsimulator ist scheißegal, wie die Bäume aussehen.
Wenn du bei einem Flugsimulator die Äste von Bäumen erkennen kannst, da hast du andere Probleme.
Läuft in der Cloud.
Ja, ich will das ja gar nicht so sehr verteufeln, ehrlich gesagt.
Das fällt nur einfach, weil die sich selbst oft mal so das Bein stellen mit ihren Versprechungen und Werbung, wo du gar nicht genau weißt, um was es eigentlich geht, aber Hauptsache 20 Buzzwords drinne.
Genauso wie vor ein paar Jahren jeder mit Cloud um sich geworfen hat und im Prinzip ist ja die Cloud auch nur quasi heiße Luft oder Wasserdampf, besser gesagt.
Weil im Prinzip ist die Cloud ja nichts anderes, wie den Rechenzentrum, was halt nicht bei dir steht.
Ich meine, guckt euch mal an, dieses ganze Microsoft Cloud-Gedöns.
Ich hatte ja letztens meine Microsoft Azure Training.
Du musst in Microsoft Azure zum Beispiel darauf achten, dass du VMs nicht irgendwie im gleichen Rack anlegst.
Hallo, was hat das mit Cloud zu tun?
Wenn ich meine VM nicht im gleichen Rack anlegen will, dann kann ich das also, naja.
Ja, du musst beispielsweise, dass du, dass du sichern kannst, dass deine VMs bei Azure nicht im gleichen Rack stehen.
Musst du irgendwie eine unterschiedliche, oh fuck, ich hab vergessen, wie es heißt, die war das Availability Zone oder so.
Nee, Availability Set musst du irgendwie anlegen und dann, oh, wie war der Kram, ich krieg's aus dem Kopf nicht mehr hin.
Und dann kannst du irgendwie unterschiedliche Zonen oder so auswählen und dann ist es nicht im gleichen Rack.
Also du musst quasi in Azure selbst dafür sorgen, dass deine VMs nicht im gleichen Rack laufen und dass du mehr als eine VM hast, wenn es ausfallen sicher ist.
Also im Prinzip ist das wirklich nur, und keine andere Cloud ist anders irgendwo, im Prinzip ist das halt einfach nur ein Rechenzentrum, was nicht bei dir liegt.
Und was halt ganz cool daran ist, ist, wenn du halt nicht das auf VM-Ebene machst, also wenn du da nicht VMs hinstellst, sondern wenn du halt die Services benutzt, die die ganzen Sachen anbieten.
Die haben zum Beispiel für die ganzen, um noch ein bisschen mehr auf dem Hype Train zu reiten.
Es gibt natürlich auch ein Hosted Kubernetes Zeug von Microsoft.
Das ist dann für die ganz Hardcore-Buzzword-Leute.
Also wenn du in Azure einen Kubernetes Cluster betreibst und darauf Blockchain machst, also dann bist du echt, dann bist du komplett next level, da bist du schon 2025.
Das hat zwar außer Buzzwords keinen tieferen Sinn, aber klingt gut.
Ja, so viel zum Thema hier, das Cloud.
Was halt ganz cool ist, wenn du fertige Services benutzt, die da sind. Aber selbst da muss man halt immer klar sein, es ist halt keine Magic.
Es ist im Prinzip einfach nur eine gut aufgebaute Infrastruktur aus global verteilten Rechenzentren, die gut miteinander verbunden sind.
Das ist alles. Das ist das ganze in Anführungstriche Geheimnis, sowohl von Microsoft als auch von Google als auch von Amazon.
Allerdings, es ist deutlich schwerer, als sich's anhört.
Microsoft hat zum Beispiel eigene Untersee-Kabel legen lassen, nur für Azure und sowas.
Deswegen, ich hatte die supernice Geschäftsidee.
Wenn man beispielsweise eine scheiß Verbindung hat, dank Telekom oder Unity Media zu sagen wir mal, wenn man irgendwie auf koreanischen Servern Overwatch spielen will oder so,
dann habe ich mir überlegt, man könnte einen Gaming-VPN anbieten. Ich weiß, dass es sowas schon gibt, aber ich würde das natürlich mehr next-level machen.
Man könnte einen Gaming-VPN anbieten, was quasi bei Microsoft Azure läuft und quasi den Microsoft Glasfaser-Backbone verwendet, um zwischen unterschiedlichen Azure-Standorten
quasi optimal die oder so schnell wie möglich weltweit die Pakete zu verteilen und dann am Ausgang zum eigenen Zielserver zu schicken.
Da müsste man nämlich mal gucken, ob das nicht sogar besser ist als die ganzen Gaming-VPN-Anbieter, die es schon gibt.
Bringt aber nichts, wenn die Verbindung zum Azure-RZ scheiße ist. Die Verbindung zum Azure-RZ ist in der Regel aber nicht scheiße,
weil es ziemlich nah bei dir dran steht und Microsoft da schon viel Wert drauf legt. Also man könnte den Gaming-VPN anbieten,
was quasi den Eingang und Ausgang in Azure hat und intern halt eben die schnelle Untersee-Glasfaser-Verbindung von Kontinent zu Kontinent von Microsoft verwendet.
Aber ehrlich gesagt ist mir das zu viel gefrickt. Aber es müsste, theoretisch müsste es ziemlich gut funktionieren.
Vielleicht probiere ich das mal aus. Ich brauche ja einfach nur zwei Server, einen in den A, einen hier, den interconnectmäßig verbinden
und dann irgendwie noch einen VPN drauf machen und mal gucken. Und dann mal gucken, wie sich NA Overwatch spielt im Vergleich zu ohne VPN.
Aber ich glaube, das wäre eine gute Geschäftsidee.
NA, ja es kann auch koreanischen Server sein, wenn man auf den Sack kriegen will in Overwatch. Korea kriegt eh den Auto-Win beim World Cup.
Haben eigentlich, das muss ich jetzt mal nachgucken, Team Germany, Overwatch, haben die jetzt eigentlich mittlerweile ihr Geld zusammen?
Ach, sie haben es auch, cool.
3000, das reicht doch hinten vorne nicht, oder? 170 Euro von 3000. 3000 Euro kommst du doch da wahrscheinlich nicht großartig aus, oder?
Es ist auf jeden Fall cool, dass sie die Kohle anscheinend zusammen haben.
Haben sie noch irgendwas geschrieben?
Also auf jeden Fall cool, dass die Leute, dass die Jungs dahin fahren können, Overwatch technisch, auf dem World Cup mitspielen.
Ich hoffe, die kommen weiter, als man das ihnen so zutraut. Gute Spiele haben sie.
Nee, ich spiele keine Overwatch mehr.
Ich habe mal wieder kurz reingeguckt, als RollQ rausgekommen ist, aber...
Also wenn die wirklich bloß 3K zusammen haben, wird das echt ein bisschen wenig, ne?
Weil das sind 6 Spieler und 2 Coaches, oder? Oder wie heißt man sich die Sachen, sag mal so.
Also ich weiß nicht, Sache 6, 7, 8 Leute, da sind 3000 Euro ganz schön wenig.
Ich denke halt mal, sie haben noch andere Quellen, ja?
Ja Leute, gut.
Ich glaube, Money werden die ja nicht verdienen. Preisgelder sind ja immer noch nicht, glaube ich, raus.
Da gibt es irgendjemand, was tauschen könnte.
Du folgst.
Wir könnten den May One Trick Spieler aus Overwatch Team Germany hosten.
Ich hoffe echt, die kommen weit.
Ich würde es ihnen echt wünschen, ganz ehrlich.
Ich finde es zwar immer noch eine Sauerei von Blizzard, dass sie den Kram nicht bezahlen.
Aber wenn ich mich darüber aufrege, kann ich auch viel heiße Luft um nichts.
Wir hosten Rady, der freut sich bestimmt.
Alles klar Leute, wir sehen uns. Bis dann, machts gut.
Wir raiden jetzt, wir raiden Rady.
Machts gut, wir sehen uns dann morgen oder so, die Tage. Bis denn, morgen gibt es ein neues Video.
Also bis denn, machts gut.
Ich kann ihn nicht helfen.